[Musique]
Messieurs, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
C'est pas préparé.
Désolé pour ce petit retard mais vas-y,
je t'en prie. Je te coupe en plus.
Je t'en prie. Sylvain Lapo je suis
journaliste et co-auteur pour le
collectif datagueul
Henri Henri Poulin réalisateur et
co-auteur de data gueule et il manque
Julien G qui qui devrait être avec nous
mais qui est retenu pour de sombres
histoires familiales non de joyeuses
histoires familiales plutôt qui est
également co-auteur coconcepteur de dat
ta gueule et qui qui fait partie du trio
initial
qui fait la voix et qui fait la voix
une sombre histoire il garde juste sa
fille
il garde son fils il a son fils joyeuse.
Et ben écoutez, on est très content de
vous revoir euh parce que vous êtes un
des piliers d'Internet avec Data Gueule.
Euh euh vous avez aussi influencé notre
façon de travailler, notre façon de voir
les choses et on est très content de
vous avoir aujourd'hui. Euh on vous
reçoit aujourd'hui pour tout un tas de
choses, pour parler futur, pour parler
euh
peut-être piste, pour voir le futur avec
un regard euh plus sain et trouver des
pistes. Donc on va parler d'utopie
aujourd'hui. va parler de aussi votre
point de vue sur l'actualité, votre
façon de travailler, qu'est-ce qui vous
anime et on est super content de vous
avoir.
Merci. Merci Skyir
et et je préviens la communauté, juste
après vous, on a une autre interview et
on parlera économie symbiotique,
économie, réchauffement climatique et
tout un tas de choses.
Henry Poulin.
Oui.
Henry, euh comment ça s'est passé le
Covid ? Est-ce que tu as eu le Covid ?
Est-ce que si tu veux en parler
d'ailleurs,
je veux bien ouais, j'ai une j'ai eu une
une version soft du covid, je m'en suis
bien sorti comme je crois 97 98 % des
gens qui le chopent. Donc je suis du bon
côté de la barrière du Covid. Euh
néanmoins, faut faire super gaffe parce
qu'on parce que c'est un truc vraiment
protéiforme. Donc voilà, j'engage tous
ceux qui ne l'ont pas encore eu, même
ceux qui l'ont eu parce qu' on peut le
on peut le rechoper paraît-il. C'est pas
précisément encore. Il y a des doutes à
continuer à faire attention malgré ce
joyeux déconfinement qui nous engage à
aller en terrasse. Il faut toujours
faire gaffe quand même.
Sylvin
euh ben moi j'ai télétravaillé comme
d'hab et j'ai cette cette pandémie et ce
déconfinement a été l'occasion pour moi
de d'aller contre une espèce de
réticence que j'avais vis-à-vis d'une
certaine communauté qui est la
communauté des makers qui est une
communauté dans laquelle je crois
profondément. Mais j'étais assez
distant. Il se trouve que je fais partie
d'une coopérative à Saint-Denis qui
s'appelle la coopérative point carré et
on a eu la on a pris la décision parce
qu'on avait plein de machine qui
traînaient d'imprimer des visières en
3D. Donc j'ai passé une bonne partie de
mon confinement avec plein de bénévoles
à bah répondre aux besoins du 93 en
terme de protection et c'était du
bénévolat, c'était des makers, c'était
open source, c'était formidable et j'en
profite pour d'ailleurs les féliciter
toutes et tous parce que ça a été une
expérience humaine et coopérative
fantastique. Voilà. En plus, c'est très
bien ce que le 93 était ou est toujours
un gros cluster. Tout à fait.
Une grosse grappe.
Tout à fait.
Pourquoi une appréhension vis-à-vis des
makers ? Euh je pense que j'avais cette
idée un petit peu euh un petit peu con
euh de euh ouais les imprimantes 3D,
c'est juste un truc pour fabriquer des
joujou en plastique moche que finalement
tu as pas enfin je ne le voyais pas
comme un vrai outil pour répondre à des
problématiques sociales. Moi ça me
faisait chier de voir des vidéos de gens
qui disaient "Ah, regarde, on a fait un
truc trop cool qui nous qui sert à rien
mais qui est joli". Et je voyais pas les
personnes qui répondaient au problème
immédiat de bah des personnes qui ont
pas les moyens, des personnes en
situation de handicap, des personnes
médicales et autres. Et là, c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait pendant pres
près de 2 mois. Ça a continué d'ailleurs
au sein de la coopérative. Euh
c'est-à-dire bah c'est une très bonne
solution d'appoint quand tu es par
exemple dans le 93 au hasard, quand tu
es par exemple à Saint-Ni au hasard et
que concrètement bah euh tout le monde
parle de la PHP, tout le monde parle des
grands hôpitaux parisiens mais euh de la
Fontaine, le CH Saint-Ni euh euh
Goussinville euh ou bien euh Stin, euh
toutes ces villes-là dans lesquelles
c'est la méga galère comme tu l'as dit
où on a installé les premières tentes de
tri pour les personnes atteintes COVID
plus. Euh mais concrètement, bah ces
gens-là sont à l'écart de tous les
circuits de solidarité, de la visibilité
médiatique. Et là, tu as une solidarité
locale qui s'est bâtie autour de
savoir-faire avec du bénévolat. Enfin,
voilà. Donc, il y a cette espèce de dou
mélange de plein de choses auquels je
crois profondément, plus cette nouvelle
fois dans dans les makers comme un vrai
voilà un vrai levier d'action politique
locale.
Je vais vous poser une question
d'ailleurs pour commencer une question
d'actualité. Quand vous avez vu la la
manifestation pour Adama Traoré hier
avec des milliers de personnes pour la
plupart qui étaient masqué mais
peut-être pas pour la plupart, est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est raisonnable de
d'aller manifester alors qu'on est
encore en circulation active de virus
sur Paris ?
Moi je pense que
c'est déraisonnable d'être victime de
violence policière avant tout.
Euh effectivement, les conditions
sanitaires plus sereines auraient été
favorables, mais ce qui motive, ceux qui
vont manifester hier, euh c'est un
soulèvement nécessaire euh en plus
motivé par une récente contrexpertise
qui révèle quand même que
Tor est pas mort comme ça, hein. C'est
pas Donc oui, je pense que cette
manifestation est légitime. Je pense
j'ai fait j'ai vu aussi comme beaucoup
que il visait attention au risque
sanitaire qui restait à distance tant
que possible. Alors, tu respondes
facilement à la distance quand tu es
gazé en même temps parce que voilà donc
c'est là aussi quand tu te prends LBD
dans la bouche,
voilà pour faire attention à ton maître
de distanciation sociale, c'est moins
c'est moins facile. Il y avait il y
avait des masques et cetera mais ce qui
était ce qui était très raisonnable,
c'était effectivement d'aller d'aller
près de de du tribunal hier pour dire ce
qu'ils avaient à dire. Pareil, je je
rejoins Henri totalement. Je pense qu'il
faut euh adapter les nouvelles les
nouvelles conditions euh enfin les
nouvelles conditions de manifestation
aux enjeux sanitaires, mais pas pour
autant renoncer à son droit de
manifester, son droit de grève. Tous les
droits sociaux, c'est des droits, donc
on doit pouvoir en user si on y retire,
c'est un problème. Et par ailleurs, les
premières personnes qu'on qui ont brisé
la disensation sociale, c'est les flics
qui ont assez à la fin. Donc pour moi,
bah ce manque de respect là, le le non
respect des enjeux sanitaires là, il est
aussi du côté des autorités. Donc faut
peut-être qu'elle se calme à un moment
et qu'elle réalise que elle foutent la
merde pour [__] la merde hein parce
que là on n pas envie d'entendre ça
maintenant en France. Et par ailleurs,
bah peut-être que ce serait bien aussi
d'avoir comme le shérif de Flint des
flics qui disent "On va garder à
distance". C'est aussi de leur
responsabilité et je les encourage à le
faire. Enfin j'espère je suis sûr qu'il
y en a qui veulent veulent le faire.
Donc date à gueule, ça fait de
l'éducation populaire, ça fait des
documentaires, ça fait tout un tas de de
b de bonnes choses. D'ailleurs, notre
communauté a exumé quelque chose de chez
vous de 2016 concernant les lobby dans
la publication des études scientifiques
qui est d'ailleurs très intéressante,
qu'on a reposté ce matin privé de
savoir, on va en reparler d'ailleurs.
On a reposté ça ce matin sur notre
compte Twitter.
Euh les violences policières euh
on en est où en France ? Est-ce qu'il y
a des Est-ce qu'il y a des raisons
légitimes d'avoir peur des flics ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des raisons légitimes
de ne pas avoir peur des flics ? Est-ce
que les flics ont des raisons légitimes
de
de taper sur les gens, d'avoir peur
aussi de se faire taper ? Je vous
écoute.
Enfin, je crois que les derniers mois,
les dernières les derniers mois, on
pouvait et je crois que le travail de
David Dufren par exemple prouve
qu'effectivement il faut faire un peu
gaffe quoi. Alors évidemment quand tu as
50 piches que tu es blanc et que tu es
dans les beaux quartiers, c'est plus
cool. Tu risques moins de choses. Euh
quand tu es de l'autre côté de cette
barrière sociale qui existe quand même,
faut arrêter de se mentir,
que tu es gilets jaune et que tu vas
mané le samedi ou que tu es en banlieu
et et que tu es un peu blague ou un peu
rebug et cetera. Ouais, là faut faire
gaffe quand même. Je comprends que les
violences policière soit enfin c'est un
sujet central en fait. C'est que il y a
pas de République digne de ce nom si une
partie de la population n'est pas traité
de la même manière que la totalité que
de de du reste. Et c'est quand même un
peu le cas. Les statistiques sont
claires, les chiffres sont clairs. Ne
parlons pas des centaines des borniers.
Enfin c'est ces derniers mois-là ont été
euh ont été assez
mutilés pour certains
mutilés mutilés pour certains sans
compter quelques morts aussi.
Donc tout ça est documenté hein, c'est
précis et cetera, malgré les dénégations
euh de ceux qui sont en charge quand
même hein. Mais non, il n'y a pas de
violence policière. Mais non, il n'y a
pas eu de euh c'est assez fou d'ailleurs
cette distance entre un réel chiffré,
documenté, factuel et euh et un discours
de communication politique euh qui le
nit complètement. Je suis sidéré par ça.
Donc c'est un sujet effectivement.
On avait envisagé d'ailleurs de le de le
traiter peut-être traitera un jour
peut-être et
peut-être qu'on traitera un jour. C'est
vrai que c'est plutôt une question de
disponibilité de données, de qualité de
la donnée. Je souscris totalement à ce
que dit Henry. Pour moi, il enfin quand
je pense à ça, je me souviens avoir été
euh sur les Champsélysé pour voir c'est
difficile d'aller dans des endroits
comme ça en étant journaliste, en étant
juste simple citoyen ou simple
citoyenne, tu vois, tu t'avances et
forcément, tu as ce regard là. Et en
fait, je me souviens de ces de ces
moments où tu voyais surgir des flics
parce que ils passaient par des
parkings, parce que il y avait des
techniques de dissimulation, parce que
plein de truc. Et en fait, ça me fait
penser à ce bouquin de Chamaayou, la
théorie du drone où en fait il explique
que les règles de la guerre ont été
totalement bouleversées par la théorie
du par le par l'apparition des drones
parce que les drones en fait, ils sont
tellement hauts en Afghanistan notamment
que tu ne les vois pas, les populations
ne les voient pas. Et elles peuvent
quand même se prendre un missile sur la
gueule qui va décimer l'intégralité de
leur village, à minimal leur famille. Et
en fait là, c'est pareil, c'estd que tu
as tu as une tu as une doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre dans laquelle très
concrètement tu as plein de règles de
base de justification de la de
l'engagement de de proportionnalité de
la réponse qui volent totalement en
éclat. Les flics peuvent se cacher, les
flics peuvent dissimuler des armes, les
flics peuvent se mêler à la foule, les
flics et d'un coup apparaître comme ça
et commencer à shooter. Et tu as eu des
mouvements de foule qui ont été
provoqués concrètement par cette
apparition des des forces de police. Les
forces de police doivent pas apparaître,
elles doivent et clairement être là. Et
j'ai vu des flics se faire passer pour
des manifestants et contrôler des gens
de en sortant juste leur badge. Mais on
n'est pas dans un [__] de western,
quoi. Il y a il y a il y a une asymétrie
qui se crée là et qui fait monter une
défiance. Je connais beaucoup de gens
qui ont beaucoup d'expérience et qui ne
vont plus manifester par peur. Et pour
moi la manifestation de quoi ?
Mais de se faire casser la gueule, de se
faire nasser, de se faire.
Il y a pas j'ai fait quelques-uns des
actes des gilets jaunes. J'y suis allé
euh parce que parce que naturellement
j'y vais. Enfin, c'est que tout peuple
qui se soulève euh est un est à enfin
est à rejoindre, me semble-t-il. Euh et
il y a pas une seule fois, je vais en
faire une dizaine des actes. J'ai pas
tous fait hein, je suis pas je suis pas
un gilet jaune spontané. Je suis quand
même un catégorisable dans le rang des
bobos si on veut catégoriser quand même.
Je fais le métier que j'aime. Je vis
très confortablement dans un quartier
populaire certes mais quand même un
quartier que j'ai choisi à Paris. J'ai
pas de voiture, j'ai pas de permis.
Vraiment le Parisien bobo par
excellence. Néanmoins mon cœur va à ce à
ces combats qui sont des des combats
nécessairement justes. Et les 10 fois où
j'y suis allé ou 11 fois ou 12 fois
peut-être, je me suis fait nassé gazé
alors que autour de moi, à l'instant où
ça se produisait, il y avait pas le
moindre le moindre mouvement de foule
violent, aucune raison objective. Donc
c'est une on est face à une stratégie
délibéré, de fragiliser le le le
mouvement euh ces mouvements-là, ces
soulèvements-là comme beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs de deux manières en les
déconsidérant aux yeux de la presse
puisqueévidemment on sait bien que s'il
y a un feu sur une trottinette tout de
suite les caméras des mediam stream vont
se jeter dessus. Ça fait de la belle
image, on peut les comprendre mais c'est
une image qui ne résume pas la réalité,
qui est pas qui est pas à la hauteur de
la réalité, de la complexité de de ce
qui engage les gens dans la rue. Et puis
deuxème stratégie, c'est effectivement
celle de bah de de terroriser au sens
premier du terme, de faire peur.
Effectivement, tu finis par avoir la
trouille quand tu te fais quand tu te
prends une charge de charge de CRS, tu
te prends un coup, tu te fais gazer, que
tu respiras pendant une demi-heure, ça
fait flipper. C'est c'est pas cool quoi.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le fait de
dénucler les gens, c'est-à-dire de leur
tirer une balle de 40 mm en plein œil
pour qu'il se balade avec l'œil comme
une balle de pingpong dans la main, on a
vu tous ces images là, le fait de voir
des gens démantibulés, le fait d'avoir
des tirs à la tête. Est-ce que à votre
avis, nous on a déjà notre conclusion
sur ce sur cette question là, est-ce
qu'à votre avis c'est une stratégie
délibérée militaire pour faire peur aux
gens pour qu'il n'aillent pas manifester
et pour leur dire écoutez vous voulez
manifester voilà à quoi vous risquez et
péril c'est une stratégie. En tout cas,
il y a quelque chose qui est clair et ça
a été documenté, y compris par d'anciens
flics, y compris par des par des par des
membres de la de la enfin de la fonction
euh au sein de du ministère de
l'intérieur. On apprend aux policiers à
tirer. Donc à moment où il faut arrêter
avec le "Ah bah je visais la chille et
je et je lui ai arraché un œil."
Il y a un moment où si c'est si les
personnes qu'on envoie sur le terrain
avec des armes qui sont catégorises dans
beaucoup de pays comme armes de guerre
euh et qui sont pas foutus de s'en
servir concrètement là c'est conseil de
discipline et on leur retire leur arme
et on les retire de ces terrain là. Il y
a donc soit il y a une erreur
d'affectation soit on leur dit que c'est
une autorisation qu'on a le droit de le
faire. Moi, je me souviens que euh sur
euh une fois en remontant euh vers les
Champsées, on m'artrait du matériel euh
parce que alors la justification c'était
j'avais j'avais des lunettes de plonger,
lunettes de natation euh et on disait
"Oui, mais vous ne devez pas vous
protéger contre les euh gaz lacrymogènes
parce que ça dénote chez vous une
intention de vous de de vous d'engager
la police." Non mais attends, mais c'est
qui qui lance les lacrimois à un moment
? Genre, c'était écrit tel quel. c'est
qu'en gros si tu essaies de te protéger,
ça veut dire que tu vas essayer de te
mettre en danger, ça veut dire que tu
vas provoquer, ça veut dire que tu es en
agression. La manife est un droit. Donc
dès le moment où tu as un seul critère,
un seul qui t'empêche d'y aller ou qui
te fait peur d'y aller parce que tu es
un enfant, parce que tu es une personne
âgée, parce que tu es asthmatique, parce
que concrètement tu te prends une une
lacrima dans la gueule, tu tu t'en
relèves pas pareil si tu as pas de
problème parce que tu es racisé, parce
que tu es une femme, parce que tu es une
personne trans, parce que tu viens de
tel quartier et cetera, tout ça ou parce
que tu es habillé d'une certaine
manière. Il y a aucune raison qui est
valable. Si c'est un droit, c'est un
droit pour tout le monde ou alors c'est
pas un droit ou alors c'est d'une
autorisation. Tu parles de stratégie, il
y a un truc moi qui m'a frappé à ces
derniers jours, c'est la séquence Trump
qui
sort de la de de de la Maison Blanche
fait quelque part en extérieur et fait
tout un discours sur
ces violences insupportables faites à la
République euh enfin à la à la
démocratie américaine euh invoquant
évidemment des groupes terroristes
antifa et tous ces et parlant de parlant
Je t'en prie. Par parlant de de de de
des résist des des manifestants comme
des comme des terroristes. Ça m'a
rappelé ça m'a rappelé Macron qui se
rend à l'Arc de Triomphe qui quelques
jours après l'acte 3 nous fait à peu
près le même schéma. En fait, il y a un
processus qui est toujours un peu
similaire. Le processus c'est je flippe
parce qu'effectivement le peuple se
soulève. Tout d'un coup, je convoque je
convoque la une démocratie. Le terme
démocratie aussi he était été évoqué par
Trump et par Macron un peu parallèlement
euh sans euh sans bien sûr définir cette
démocratie. On sait bien que la
démocratie qu'ils qu'ils évoquent, elle
n'a pas beaucoup de sens cette démoc
représentative. C'est si jamais un
peuple se soulève, tu as envie d'écouter
le peuple. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On
on fait des violences policières à
l'encontre des noirs aux États-Unis. On
on fait on fait un grand débat national,
un réel, pas on en parle, on réforme la
police, on engage. Non, c'est pas c'est
pas ce qui est fait évidemment, on on
incrimine les manifestants
et on justifie par la même les violences
à venir, les violences policières à
venir et la répression à venir qui a
encore une fois cette double fonction de
discréditer le mouvement et de
brutaliser. Et donc
pourquoi la répression va venir ? Et ça
a été dit hein parce que aux États je
parle aux États-Unis
ou mais en France aussi.
Oui.
Parce que ça a été dit par certains
ministres en disant si vous allez dans
la rue c'est vous rendez complice. Genre
vous manifestez au côté de gens vous
rendez complice. Vous entendez tu as une
espèce de suspicion genre tu es tu es
enfin qui par ailleurs hein juste pour
pour rappel hein pour qui n'a pas fait
d'études de droit ce qui manque cas
aussi mais dans les bases c'est fin de
la présence d'innocence. Tu es dans la
rue donc tu es coupable. Tu as rien fait
mais tu es tu es tu es complice dans le
droit français. complice, tu as la même
sanction que le coupable. Donc
concrètement, à cet égard, on considère
que bah tu peux t'en prendre autant dans
la gueule que les mecs qui que les mecs
qui cassent.
Et par ailleurs euh encore une fois,
enfin bon là c'est pas du tout dans
l'ordre de l'encouragement, mais c'est
juste de constater que on en vient
sérieusement à justifier le fait de de
de
d'handicaper des personnes, de leur
enfin de les de les mettre en situation
de d'être mutilé de mutiler des
personnes, pardon pour le terme de
handicap, de mutiler des personnes au
nom de la destruction de la propriété
privée.
Un œil combien ça coûte. Alors les
sociétés d'assurance et
surtout la protection du pouvoir en
place
et la protection d'une image. Une image
de la police image du pouvoir en place.
Une image à stabilité de l'État de
l'État. C'est pas la démocratie Henry a
raison. L'invocation à la démocratie ici
elle est totalement elle est totalement
malhonnête. C'est l'État l'intégrité de
l'État.
Comment vous comment vous anticipez
l'avenir socialement parlant,
économiquement parlant ? Comment
vous percevez le les choses ? Vous avez
fait beaucoup de
choses sur l'économie, sur les lobbys,
sur l'écologie, sur tout un tas de
sujets. Vous en tant qu'individu, en
tant que producteur, data, journaliste,
comment vous vous sentez notre notre
avenir à court et moyen terme ? Alors, à
court terme, pour l'année à venir,
est-ce que vous voyez
des chamboulements dans les élections ?
Est-ce que vous voyez des chamboulements
en terme de chômage, en terme de choses
comme ça ? Si vous faites des
investissements, où est-ce que vous
investissez votre pognon ?
Allez-y les gars. Alors pourquoi tu
regardes ton patron comme ça là ? C'est
pas mon patron, on est on est on est on
est collaborateur. On est
et mon ami et on est et amis et
collègues mais on est
Non, c'est juste je me disais du coup je
sais pas si on est plutôt à météo France
ou
non mais en fait je pense que moi je
sais pas ce qui va se passer. Je suis
pas devin et j'ai pas je suis pas en
capacité de savoir
ça s sapin ? Est-ce que ça sense pas le
sapin ?
Alors après ce que je sais c'est est-ce
que je crains ? Est-ce que j'espère ?
Voilà et je sais pas si la réalité sera
entre l'un et l'autre entre ce que je
crains et ce que j'espère. Moi ce que je
je crains effectivement c'est un
renforcement des rapports de force et
des rapports de domination de la part de
ceux qui ont le pouvoir et qui veulent
décidément pas le lâcher. Alors ils sont
ils sont c'est c'est protéformes ceux
qui ont le pouvoir hein. C'est
effectivement
les gouvernants. Je parle pas qu'en
France hein, on peut parler d'Erdogan,
de Trump, de Boris Johnson, Wolsonaro et
beaucoup d'autres. Pas des grands
démocrates au sens de gens qui ne
possent pas tellement temps que ça
finalement le pouvoir du peuple par le
peuple pour le peuple. C'est ça la
démocratie.
et et White Chopper effectivement que ce
que les rapport de force c'est également
dans les principes de domination les
blanc sur les les racisés, les hommes
sur les femmes ces rapports de
domination se sont de plus en plus
brutaux, violents, de moins en moins euh
enfin ça je suis surpris par la
régression finalement des rapports de
force et des de l'intensité des rapports
de force qui vont créer Chendo, toujours
en défaveur bien sûr de ceux qui sont
pas du bon côté de de la norme.
Donc je crains que ça s'implifie et
j'observe que ça s'amplifie.
Et ce que j'espère c'est un soulèvement.
Ce sont des soulèvements. Un soulèvement
c'est pas seulement la révolution est
tirée dans le tas. Se soulever c'est
c'est c'est ne plus se soumettre à la
domination. C'est se c'est dire quand on
est une femme, quelqu'un de racisé,
une cuire,
un un curde, dire non, je je suis pas
d'accord pour pour me soumettre à cette
ceation et non seulement je suis pas
d'accord, mais de surcroix, ma révolte,
ma ma mon soulèvement va être un
soulèvement de construction. Je vais
proposer des alternatives. Je vais vous
prouver qu'on peut faire mieux dans le
respect des autres. Je parle dans un
processus de vengeance, tu m'as fait
mal, je te ferai mal en retour. c espèce
de binarisation du réel ou si tu es pas
pour moi, tu es contre moi et donc comme
tu as été contre moi, je vais être
contre toi. C'est espèce de truc de très
très frontal, très basique dont se
nourrit la vie politique française,
européenne, états-unienne. C espèce de
truc, ce piège immense dans lequel on
tombe tous peu à peu. Et c'est terrible
dire voilà, on en parlera plus tard. Je
sais pas pourquoi je glisse là-dessus
très rapidement mais c'est une obsession
du moment. La la je vois j'observe ce
qui s'est passé en la Rojava et qui est
peut-être l'un des l'un des sujets qu'on
va aborder je l'espère dans le cadre de
nos série documentaires utopie de mot
la Rojava le le le c'est le c'est le
nord de de la Syrie, le Kurdistan syrien
c'est une région qui a été conquise par
Daesh et l'is très tôt
en 2014 à la faveur de de la la
le le le mouvement de révolution
anti-assad et cette région là a été
libéré
par les troupes du PKK qui sont
transformées en IPK et IPJ, donc des
troupes majoritairement curdes mais pas
seulement qui ont rallé sous leur
drapeau également des sunnites, des
chiites, des syriacques, des araméens,
des l'intégralité des confessions de la
région, c'est un territoire
multiconfessionnel, multiethnique, mais
euh en les reliant autour d'une d'une
d'un combat laïque et fondament
fondamentalement politique de
fédéralisme. Voilà, il pu il faut sortir
de l'état nation d'une structure
verticale où il s'agirait de se
soumettre qui a Erdogan, qui a Assad,
qui à la à l'atel du moment. Non, en
fait chacun est maître de son de son
espace, de sa communauté et doit et on
doit interagir et décider ensemble avec
de surcroix dans cette région du monde
que l'on dit particulièrement patriarcal
en imposant une révolution féministe
réelle où l'ensemble des postes de de
direction de décision sont
fondamentalement paritaires. Tous les
postes sont doublés où les femmes sont
également des combattantes et ces
gens-là, ils ont foutu de la pâtie à
Daesh. 7 aidé par les par les Américains
et un peu les Français aussi he les les
les les les les commandau français ont
filé un coup de main également. Euh ils
ont sur sur un un espace qui est à peu
près grand comme la Belgique à quelques
dizaines à quelques centaines milliers
de kilomètres près carré près. Donc
c'est un territoire de 5 6 7 millions
d'habitants. Ça a très bien fonctionné
jusqu'en 2019 jusqu'au moment où
évidemment ce modèle là il plaît pas à
Erdogan. Le le ce ce certains
modèle de quoi ? D'un Kurdistan libre.
un Kurdistan enfin fédéraliste
démocratique
démocratique réellement débré au sens
premier du terme
et donc après libre
et donc potentiellement libre mais ceci
dit à ce moment-là cette cette
expérience là elle est pas en Turquie
elle est en Syrie.
Elle est à la frontière de la de la de
la Turquie certes mais elle est pas en
Turquie. Il y a aucune raison que les
cules interviennent. Sauf que ce modèle
là ne doit pas se transmettre. Faut
surtout pas que ça fasse tâche d'huile.
Donc il faut bombarder. Il y a aucune
revendication territoriale de la part
d'Erdogan. Ce les bombes elles n'ont
qu'une seule et unique elles n'ont qu'un
objectif c'est faire terantir les
Kurdes.
Pardon ?
C'est d'anéantir les Kurdes.
Ouais. Enfin d'anéantir les curdes ce
côté nationaliste, mais également côté
politique. C'est qu'en fait il y a
plusieurs il y a deux mouvements kurdes
pour simplifier. Il y a un mouvement
nationaliste, PK.
Euh non, le le le le le parti démocrate
qui parfois est allié d'ailleurs au aerd
de GAN pour attaquer les bases arrières
du PKK dans le euh dans dans le
Kurdistan iakien étonnamment. Non, c'est
surtout je crois c'est au-delà même de
donc de la revendication nationaliste
curde d'un côté, turc de l'autre, il y a
surtout en fait là dans dans le cas de
la Rojava une revendication politique.
C'est que le les cur nous on veut pas
curdiser la région. Il y a des dizaines
de communautés différentes. On veut
travailler avec les Arabes, on trava les
Assyriens, avec les Syriacques, on veut
travailler avec la totalité et puis on
est laïque. Il est pas question
effectivement que la foi personnelle
c'est c'est extrêmement progressiste. Ça
ça va s'en dire dans l'absolu. Mais
là-bas et même ici d'ailleurs, c'est
compliqué de d'avoir un un une vision
aussi aussi égalitaire, aussi paritaire,
aussi
comment ils ont senti de se faire
abandonner par leurs alliés occidentaux
?
Comment ils l'ont senti ?
Ils l'ont senti difficilement. Non. Ah
c'est c'est une trahison monumentale.
Ils ont ils ont été les bras armés de
contre Daesh pendant pendant 4 5 ans.
Des sacrifices considérables hein, des
centaines des milliers de morts hein,
hommes, femmes, voilà et qui sont allés
très vaillamment euh et ils ont gagné
quoi. Euh un peu aidé mais en logistique
quoi, tu vois avec je te file un drone
pour cartographifier le truc, je je
t'envoie quelques commandos pour pour
soutien. 99 % des gens en armes, c'était
c'était le le le le pays grec
PIG et PIJ masculin et féminin et pas
simplement les curdes encore une fois,
il y avait également de c'était
multiconfessionnel et c'est une trahison
monumentale. Voilà évidemment que les
que aujourd'hui ce qui pardon
pourquoi pourquoi on les a abandonné ?
Je je voulais pas interrompre Henry
parce que c'est vraiment un sujet qui
tient très à cœur et ça ça me enfin je
suis beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
documenté que lui sur le sur le sujet
mais je voudrais pas le
Pourquoi l'abandon ? Mais non c'est là
c'est des c'est la géopolitique entrée
au lieu. Je t'apprends rien. Tu tu vois
le truc ? Enfin tout d'un coup
je veux je veux t'entendre dire
mais non mais ça ça négocie entre
Poutine, Erdogan Trump je te file je te
je te laisse frine puis après je
reprendrai Cobané puis cette région là
puis a du pétrole aussi. Erdogan,
Erdogan, on lui dit "Bon, on ferme les
yeux puis comme ça tu gardes les
réfugiés chez toi." Non
mais aussi
l'Europe l'Europe est terrible. Et et de
sur quoi ?
Pourquoi l'Europe est terrible ? Mais
parce que alors l'Europe, elle vend des
armes aujourd'hui. Ce qui ce qui
bombarde les les Turcs, c'est quand même
c'est ce sont des des missiles pour
certains français, des chars allemands,
il y a des des des armes italiennes.
Enfin, l'UE a vendu des armes à Erdogan
et on va encore, ils sont membres de
l'OTAN, donc ils ont tous les droits,
même s'ils achètent aussi des missiles à
la Russie, ce qui énerve un peu Trump
qui non achète à moi l'argent vient. Le
seul enjeu réel, hein, c'est ça. C'est à
qui tu achètes tes armes. La la nation
turque, le l'expérience politique de
fédéralisme qui préserve la paix, qui
redistribue ça, c'est rien, ça n'existe
pas. Ça se négocie comme quelques barils
de pétrole sur un coin de table entre
ces grandes secondes.
Sylvain, est-ce que tu as étudié le
problème migratoire en Grèce
récemment ? Oui,
je pas assez pour
Tu n'as pas regardé notre superbe
interview de Jean Zigler qui a donné du
Excellente. Excellente
et pourtant et pourtant c'est quelqu'un
de très recommandable. De quoi tu
voulais parler ? Bah
ce qui se passe à l'esbosfug.
J'aime pas j'aime pas parler de trucs
sur c'est c'est tout à ton honneur.
Je préfère pas mais juste je voulais
rebondir parce que Henry a a longuement
parlé de la Rojava et très bien et je me
verrais mal relancer là-dessus parce que
encore une fois je connais beaucoup
moins le sujet que lui. Mais en fait
quand tu disais comment est-ce qu'on va
rebattre les cartes ? En fait, moi une
partie de ma de ma réponse tient dans
cette espèce de profusion complètement
stérile de d'appel à un nouveau monde
qui se multiplie dans tous les coins de
l'échiquier politique français. Donc, tu
as notamment eu la grande pétition de la
gauche unie mais sans certaines
personnes euh qui va tout résoudre les
problèmes et cetera. Et j'ai j'en
parlais récemment notamment avec Usul
qui est un un quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup et avec qui on débar
régulièrement. Jean Massier aussi. Et
c'était vraiment cette idée de j'ai
l'impression que tu as des tuas tu as
des gens qui vraiment ne veulent pas
changer leur affiche électorale.
Vraiment vraiment vraiment. Ils veulent
continuer d'avoir des mecs blancs qui se
présentent dans des grandes villes et
cetera et ils sont prêts à [__] une
gonzesse derrière vaguement. Tu vois
peut-être quelqu'un de racisé de temps
en temps. Un jeune pas
goness ici.
Pardon ?
On dit pas gonzesse.
Mais c'est je parlais à leur place.
C'est comme ça qu'ils en parlent. Mais
tu verras apparaître une femme quand ça
les arrange, une personne racisée quand
ça les arrange, euh une personne trans.
Bon, pour l'instant euh c'est euh quasi
euh inconnu au bataillon. Il y a une
personne qui s'occupe du numérique à la
à la à la FI qui s'occupe de ces
questions-là et qui est remarquable.
Mais à part ça, la plupart sont
totalement invisibilisées. Et c
la
France insoumise, pardon.
Et en gros, j'ai l'impression que tous
ces gens finalement ne veulent pas
changer leur programme. Par contre, ça
les arrangerait vachement si vous pouvez
mettre une petite étiquette en disant
d'utres programme et socialiste, tralala
et écologiste et féministe et ce truc.
Sauf que pour moi la vraie réponse c'est
retourner le toute la logique derrière
ça. C'estàd que si tu continues de te
dire comment je fais pour garder le même
programme mais pour rajouter des trucs
en dessous qui vont nous permettre de
faire entendre que on est quand même un
peu féministe, on est quand même un peu
pro LGBT et cetera, je veux dire
typiquement tu me parlais de lesbos
fameuse pétition de la gauche mon cul là
euh les migrants. Les quoi ? Les
migrants, le mot n'apparaît pas. la
crise migratoire. la crise migratoire
qui quand même une expression de de
réactionnaire de droite he mais la crise
pas c'est une expression de
réactionnaire de droite
la crise migratoire mais parce que
regarde enfin regarde juste les flux
dont on parle regarde les pays d'où ils
viennent les endroits où ils arrivent
très peu de choses changent en fait
enfin je veux dire c'est un c'est un
flux permanent qui
le flux le flux il est pas permanent le
flux il est au compte de goutte là il y
a 2 millions de personnes en Turquie au
Liban au Liban doit y en avoir 2
millions. Ce que je veux dire c'est la
crise migratoire c'est pas en France. Il
y a des crises migratoires ça. En
Turquie, au Liban, va leur en parler et
ça c'est
au Liban, ça double leur population.
C'est ça n'a rien à voir. Et et encore
une fois, Sabra et Chatila, c'était le
même genre de de de tension liée à des
très gros déplacements de population.
Mais là, on parle pas de ça. La France
ne vit pas une crise migratoire, c'est
des conneries. C'est une c'est une c'est
une
une mystification d'un phénomène qui
reste finalement marginal comparé à
beaucoup d'autres problèmes sociaux
économiques qui par contre passe au
second au second rang et qui concerne
généralement les personnes les personnes
en question. Combien tu as lu d'articles
sur les les migrants et migrantes qui
sont retrouvés pendus qui se suicident
en se jetant dans le canal
suicide des mineurs ? On a reçu Jean
Zigler. Ouais mais même Non mais nous
n'allons pas à Lesbos allons à
Saint-Denis. Demande aux gens du comité
solidarité migrant Wilson. Demande-leur
combien ils retrouvent de personnes qui
se sont donnés la mort après avoir reçu
les lettres de l'administration
française leur disant que leur demande
était repoussée, que leur demande de
avait passé en deuxème examen.
Demande-leur combien de ces personnesl
combien de enfin on parle de leur
désespoir non ? On va expliquer que bah
ils ont des tentes un peu sales. Oui.
Alors ils murent de faim aussi
accessoirement. Il mort de froid, il
mort de soif mais
de tristesse aussi. et de tristesse et
de désespoir parce que franchement
partir en laissant derrière toi sa
famille juste pour être sûr de peut-être
survivre à un moment voilà ça c'est
question là etelle elle elle c'est où
dans la pétition de la gauche humaniste
soi-disant et cetera c'est où c'est où
nulle part ça d'un point de vue
électoral c'est quand même pas top top
en fait on a un problème quand même
c'est que c'est que la la l'obsession
électorale l'obsession électoralist être
élu au prochaines esséances une fois
qu'on l'a été gardé ça tue totalement la
pensée politique c'estd que on on pense
plus le monde. On on tente plus des
propositions, on n'écoute plus les
autres d'ailleurs, on n plus dans le
dans l'élaboration et la confrontation
avec cette complexité infinie qui est la
réalité et qui c'est une complexité
infini qui se renouvelle à chaque à
chaque seconde, chaque jour. Non, on est
dans le programme susceptible de séduire
un électorat. C'est de la com, c'est pas
de la public, c'est pas de la politique.
C'est la publicité, c'est pas de la
politique. Ces gens-là ne font pas de
politique. C'est pas vrai. S'ils font du
positionnement.
Voilà. Je et je voulais juste revenir
sur cette histoire de pétition parce que
ce que tu dis c'est ça va totalement
dans ce sens-là. Le problème c'est quand
tu fais une pétition. C'est quoi
l'efficacité d'une pétition ? C'est
d'avoir le maximum de signataires, des
gens visibles et cetera. Donc en fait
qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Et bien pour
avoir plus de gens tu vas la vider de
toute ambition parce que un tel une
telle va dire ouais ce passage là ça
m'arrange pas trop. Est-ce qu'on peut
réécrire ? D'accord. Mais tu signes.
D'accord. Et du coup tu vas vider
progressivement à mesure que sans pile
les signatures tu les vides
progressivement. On l'a vu avec la
fameuse position des personnalités qui
veulent changer le monde et cetera, qui
politiquement est assez finalement
inodore, incolore et et inoffensive
politiquement.
Insipide.
Insipide mais inoffensive surtout
politiquement. Ça ça ne crée rien. Donc
pour répondre à la question que tu
posais au départ, moi l'avenir pour moi
précisément il il s'écrit et il
s'invente en dehors de ses cadres
institutionnels, électoraux, nationaux,
même régionaux. Je crois de plus en plus
l'expérience dont je te parlais tout à
l'heure à Saint-Ni et en pleine commune
des visières de protection qui ont été
fabriquées comme ça sur des demandes
locales avec des savoir-faires locaux
avec des matériaux locaux tout ça bah ça
me fait penser que il y a beaucoup de
solutions, beaucoup de de prise de
conscience que finalement on viendra pas
nous aider. On viendra pas nous aider.
Donc on va pas se on va pas se casser le
cul à essayer de jouer le jeu de la
capitale, le jeu euh de l'Union
nationale de d'alliance contre nature et
euh de de vider tout programme de sa
substance pour éventuellement à terme
avoir peut-être une mesure qui va dans
notre sens. Non, ce qu'on va faire,
c'est qu'on va faire le truc chez nous,
nous-mêmes dans des communautés qui sont
des communautés territoriales, des
communautés d'intérêt et dans lesquelles
et bah bizarrement ton voisin, même s'il
est arabe, tu lui files un coup de main
parce que c'est ton voisin, tu le
connais. Et bizarrement, bah la il y a
beaucoup de solidarité qui se créent
au-delà des des soi-disants clivages
irréconciliables entre les religions,
entre les ethnies, mon cul sur le
terrain, c'est dans ces communautés là
où se crée des solutions, ça n'existe
plus. Ça se dissou dans cette solidarité
locale. Moi le national, j'y crois pas.
J'y crois plus.
Oui. Oui, effectivement. Enfin, ça
n'empêche pas non plus de se soulever
contre l'institution. Et vous avez pas
pensé à vous soulever en terme
de fiscalité,
c'est-à-dire c'estdoncer à payer ses
impôts ou
c'est-à-dire payer vos impôts à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations tant
que on narrête pas de tirer dans la
bouche des gilets jaunes. payer ses
impôts
un peu comme sorrow quoi
qu' peu comme
non mais oui désobéissance civile par
l'impôt c'est payer ses vous continuez
de payer vos impôts mais vous les vous
les faites séquestrer à la caisse des
dépôts tant que les infirmières elles
sont pas à dom c'est ce qu' fait Henry
David Toro avec Waldon c'était il a
refusé de payer ses impôts en disant que
on entretenait une guerre inique contre
le Mexique
et du coup bah voilà c'était cidé de je
ne finai pas avec mes impôts. Il était
pas contre le principe de l'impôt, il
était contre le principe de l'usage qui
en était fait. Et en l'occurrence, enfin
ce que tu dis est juste. Et la question
c'est l'un des principaux débats
démocratique et l'une des principales
justifications démocratiques. On avait
fait un épisode sur le sujet, c'est
s'app
Oh purée ! sur l'impôt
sur l'impôt
avec Pr Ludowski
Pr Ludowski qui l'une des l'une des
principales enfin chevill ouvrière du
mouvement des gilets jaunes enfin qui a
qui a lancé une grande partie du
mouvement et en fait c'est cette idée
que l'une des principales
mesures enfin il y a un rapport direct
entre représentation et imposition no
taxation without representation c'était
le slogan des colons américains à
l'occasion de la Boston Party. Donc là,
c'est c'est ce principe, c'est ce moment
où tu vas dire bah en fait j'accepte de
payer des impôts si les personnes qui
décident leur usage me représente.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle représente exactement
les personnes qui aujourd'hui dirigent
flèchent nos impôts pour ainsi dire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'elles représente ? La
question de la peau est vachement
intéressante. Euh ce que ce qu'on a
abordé en en filigrane juste au tout
début dans les épisodes sur euh sur les
sur l'impôt euh on voulait le point de
départ c'est de de répondre à cette
espèce de critique et de dire les gilets
jaunes ils pensent qu'aux taxes vraiment
ils sont pas généreux, ils sont pas
écolos, ils veulent pas payer de taxes
gazoiles. Donc euh ce sont des ce sont
des beaufes, ils réfléchissent pas bien.
Ils sont pas éclos
ils sont pas écolo en plus. une connerie
la la le questionnement de la peau et de
la taxe et de sa justice
et de son et son égalité est une
question centrale et elle est à ce point
central qu'elle a préfiguré
la révolution française. Elle a même
permise la révolution française. Il faut
savoir que lorsque Neer, enfin Louis X
mais en fait Neer convoque les États
généraux, c'est parce que les caisses de
l'État sont vide et et qu'il souhaite
demander aux Aristos et à l'église de
payer leur du il y a que le tier d'État
qui paye. Et comme les mecs ils disent
non en fait non, on paye pas notre DU,
on a pas on pas payé nous le tiers État,
il y a que nous qui contribuons
finalement. Là, je schématise à
l'extrême hein, je crois a des
historiens mais écoute, ils vont ils
vont m'en violer mais a il y a une ligne
de force là. euh disent si nous sommes
les seuls à contribuer mais nous sommes
les seuls à faire à faire nation nous
sommes il s'autoproclament assemblée
nationale et ça préfigure et ça permet
effectivement la révolution française
que l'on que l'on mytifie aujourd'hui
mais dont on se garderait bien de
reproduire finalement les intensités
réelles enfin quand on est au pouvoir.
Il y a il y a un truc quand même qui est
très amusant quand tu quand tu très
amusant mon humour. Euh quand tu
consultes les les débats à l'assemblée
et les débats avec les représentants
enfin représentant et représentantes non
représentants à l'époque à les droits de
l'homme. Euh c'est euh la raison pour
laquelle les le clerger et la noblesse
refusent de payer l'impôt. C'est pas
pour des raisons économiques en fait.
Quand tu regardes les arguments du
clerger c'est c'est nous allons nous
dégrader, nous allons nous rabaisser
nous allons nous rabaisser à payer des
impôts comme la pleb. C'est ils s'en
s'en va en ils s'en battent les
couilles. En l'occurrence, je peux dire
ils s'en battent les couilles. C'est
c'est parce que c'est payer des impôts.
Faut
pas dire couill non plus.
C'est c'est payer des impôts, c'est se
rabaisser toute ressemblance avec une
certaine catégorie de contribuables qui
évitent l'impôt aujourd'hui et purement
fortuite. Et purement fortite. Tu vois
le clerger
le clerger refuse de payer l'impôt parce
que ce serait se comporter comme le
peuple.
Est-ce qu'il faut lutter sans violence
ou est-ce qu'il faut lutter avec
violence ?
Très vaste question. J'ai pas la
réponse. J'ai pas la réponse. Alors ça
dépend. Moi,
tu es pas équipé pour être violent toi
non plus. Mais bon,
c'est vrai, c'est vrai, je suis un peu
faible mais je pourrais me renforcer.
Non, non, en fait, je crois que la même
manière que il peut pas y avoir une
proposition de régime ou de solution de
solution une bonne fois pour toutes sur
l'intégralité des territoires, des pays
et cetera, il y a pas aussi une seule
stratégie qui fonctionne. Ça dépend des
contextes, ça dépend des moments, ça
dépend de
de de 1000 de 1000 paramètres. Et il est
possible effectivement que la violence
soit parfois légitime. Elle l'a été le
14 juillet 1789 que l'on vénère. Elle a
été mais je pense que la la violence de
la commune de Paris
était plutôt plutôt légitime. Peut-être
que certaines violences à venir le
sauront également même si la violence
pour la violence est bien sûr toujours à
tenter d'éviter autant que possible
parce que on sait ce qu'elle génère. ce
que je génère également comme mécanique
de vengeance, de justification d'une
surviolence par la suite, d'un de
réponse non proportionnée. La violence
pour la violence, non. Mais si
effectivement c'est impératif, si
effectivement tu peux résister, que tu
as pas d'autres possibilités, pourquoi
pas ? Je vais pas d'un point de vue
moral moi pointer du doigt les ceux qui
ont recours à la à la violence. Je je
vais un peu retourner la la
réflexion parce que pour moi
aujourd'hui, il est très difficile
d'avoir une action politique non pas
sans être auteur ou autrice de violence
mais sans être la cible potentielle de
violence. Si tu vas aujourd'hui sur les
terrains d'action euh qui sont les
terrains de la représentation, de la
manifestation, de la contestation, tu
t'exposes euh objectivement à une
violence, une violence physique de plus
en plus souvent, hein. C'est plutôt ça
plus de tendance à se généraliser qu'à
se rétrécir le spectre de la violence
physique, mais aussi une violence
morale, une violence psychologique. tu
t'exposes à être traîné dans la boue, à
ce qu'on viole ton intimité, à ce qu'on
voilà, je considère que bah être l'objet
de surveillance, c'est une forme de de
violence aussi, de violation de ta vie
privée et c'est quelque chose auquel tu
t'exposes mécaniquement des l'ordre que
tu rentres dans un c lors que tu rentres
dans un certain niveau d'engagement
politique.
Tu veux rebondir sur l'engagement
politique ?
Non, ben faut l'engagement politique. Je
pense que c'est c'est un engagement de
vie en fait aussi. Là aussi, je pense
que je je je tise un sujet qui qui m'est
cher et don parlerons par la suite. Non,
pas que la RJAV, les utopies. C'estd que
c'est pas on va revenir mais c'est pas
juste que l'engagement politique c'est
aussi c'est un engagement de vie. En
fait, tu veux pas dire tiens voilà, je
vais faire je vais faire politique entre
18h et 19h ou en rendant à telle
réunion. Euh tout est politique. La vie
de la cité, onne les animaux sociaux, on
vit avec les autres. bouteill d'eau sont
politiques.
Il y a pas il y a pas un instant il y a
pas un instant de notre vie qui ne soit
pas finalement engagé par des questions
politiques et qui n'en soulèvent pas.
Alors, vous avez une chaîne internet qui
est quand même sacrément balaise.
Euh vous faites des sacrés bons
programmes, vous lisez les les
commentaires des différentes
communautés. Est-ce que vous avez senti
qu'il y a des communautés qui se
radicalisent ?
Oui.
Est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous avez senti euh une
violence particulière émerger et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la loi Avia
? Oh [__] au secours !
Voilà alors deux choses de choses
différent. On va distinguer. On va
distinguer. Tu feras Avia juste un truc
sûr. Non non, je Tu feras Avia. C'est
cadeau. Tu l'as fait récemment très
bien. Euh non.
Le privilège de l'âge hein.
On a on a été très très privilégié
pendant des années. On a commencé en
2014 jusqu'en 2018 2019 il y a encore un
an, un an et demi. C'était plutôt cool
nos nos les réactions et les
commentaires. Alors il y a une raison à
cela, c'est qu'en fait depuis le départ
on dit nous on n pas on n pas de raison.
Enfin on a pas de raison. On n' pas
raison. On a des raisons. On n' pas on
n' pas raison. Euh on ne propose pas
quelque chose d'en haut. On est c'est on
partage des des questionnements, on
partage une enquête, on partage nos
sources qui nous permettent de faire une
enquête. Euh l'objet finalement qu'on
propose en terme de enfin audiovisuel,
c'est un c'est un objet qui doit être
discuté. Ce qui compte, c'est pas le
pavé et la marre, c'est l'onde entre que
le pavé provoque dans la mar. C'est le
mouvement, donc la discussion. Et et si
je me suis trompé sur un truc, très
bien, parlons-en. Euh on on nourrit ça.
C'est que on est sur le web, on n'est
pas en linéaire, on n'est pas à la
téloche, c'est pas diffusé une fois
bonne fois pour toutes. Tu peux
commenter, tu peux aller dans les
métadonnées pour cliquer sur les sources
qui sont effectivement consultables.
Donc c'est un espace de discussion. Mais
pendant effectivement 5 ans 4 ans et
demi, 5 ans c'était super cool
et soudain
et puis non parce alors il y a des
sujets qui ont chauffaient un peu, il y
en a plusieurs. Il y a une période
alors le féminisme dès que tu parles
d'abord le le féminisme, il y a tout
d'un coup une espèce alors je crois ils
sont pas ils sont pas très nombreux he
quelques dizaines quelques centaines
grand max de de masculinistes de types
qui peut-être n'ont pas de cause donc
ils ont joui celle-ci parce qu'ils
s'embêtent je sais pas je vois pas
d'autres raisons qui ne supportent pas
l'idée qu'on évoque le patriarcat les
féminicides les violences faites aux
femmes, le le principe de domination de
l'homme sur la femme donc le patriarcat
que tout que tout observateur digne de
ce nom observe. Alors après, on tient
différentes conclusions, mais mais on
peut pas dire non, il le patriar
n'existe pas. On peut dire non, il n'y a
pas. Et qui choisissent, il dit voilà,
c'est pas la bonne, c'est pas c'est pas
le bon combat. Ce qui est important
c'est les les les riches contre les
pauvres, ça c'est un combat ou le mais
les femmes ou les hommes contre les
femmes, non. C'est qu'en fait qui
choisissent hiérarchisent leur combat,
leur domination, il trouvent que des
dominçons sont supportables. Celle-ci
est donc le serait visiblement non
seulement elle est supportable mais de
sur quoi ? Il est insupportable qu'on a
qu'on la qu'on l'évoque, qu'on en parle
et ça c'est assez récent. C'est très
surprenant les réfléchissez discuter et
même si tu es pas d'accord m'insulte
pas. Il y a pas de raison pourquoi tu
m'insultes. C'était cétait fragile sur
ce trucl sur ce sujet. Qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça
bouscule en toi pour pour engendrer
cette espèce de flot
de de cette logorée un peu absurde qui a
pas de sens, qui se nourrit rien d'autre
que d'énergie. Voilà. Bon,
qui est pas argumenté
qui est pas argumenté. Voilà. C'est pas
c'est pas ce sont pas les seuls he c'est
ça c'est un groupe si en citer un qui
effectivement qu'on a vu euh
quoi d'autre ? Alors, je pense qu'il y a
aussi tous les les pros élites, les les
les dogmatiques, ceux qui considèrent
que bah il y a un homme providentiel, il
y a une réponse. Pourquoi on commence à
on continue à se poser des questions ?
Il y a une solution, je vais pas citer
nom. Euh parce que puisque moi ça
partiraent évidemment, peu importe, mais
voilà, les les dogmatiques, eux, ils
savent. Donc euh nous, on évoque
d'autres choses, une pluralité de
possibilités puison une complexité, une
pluralité de facteurs. Voilà. Et puis à
chacun après de de de cheminer de
confusionniste parce que tu abordes
différents sujets, que tu as pas choisi
ton camp. B non enfin ce serait
compliqué quand même. Ce serait pas
encore on n pas eu mais c'est
moquant qui fait réagir. Mais
non mais c'est en fait c'est ça mais tu
vois ça c'est le c'est leur leur
vocabulire. Mais
effectivement si tu es pas dans leur
camp c'est que tu es contre eux. Si tu
ne penses pas exactement comme ce groupe
ou c'est un et bien mécaniquement tu es
contre.
C'est pas ça. C'est pas le cas aussi
chez les féministes.
J'ai pas l'impression. Je pense que
c'est vraiment
pas des des féministes radicalisés.
en fait peut-être qu' qui durcissent
leur discours dans certains mots. Moi,
j'ai j j'ai jamais été euh choqué par
des discours exagérément féministe. Je
pense que la réaction et je suis sur
quoi ? Je suis toujours du côté de ceux
qui prennent des beignes quoi, tu vois.
Et je pense que tu peux avoir des
réactions un peu dures quand tu te
prends une baigne et pour l'instant
c'est pas les mecs blancs qui qui se
prent les baign.
Je pense pas que tu as plus t de
féministes radicalisés que de personnes
racisées radicalisées. He c'est le le
fait d'être soumis d'être soumis à une
forme de violence stat
hein. Tuas des stats ? Non, mais je je
te parle vraiment du discours que
j'entends et j'écoute beaucoup de de
féministes, mais je je pense que dans le
discours, il y a un moment où tu as tu
as un niveau de de violence verbale, y
compris, qui et d'accumulation qui est
telle que tu as des personnes qui
peuvent avoir une expression qui semble
qui peut choquer et qui nous et qui
m'aime à l'alaise et qui m'aime à l'aise
à forcerie l'homme blanc 6 que je suis.
Pareil avec des personnes tranches,
c'est quoi 6 ? euh si, c'est-à-dire euh
né homme euh né homme enfin assigner
homme à la naissance et par la personne
trans. Euh du coup, je pense que dans
mon univers de représentation, dans mon
vécu à moi, ces violences verbales-là,
ces violences systémiques, ces violences
sociétales, elles sont pas aussi
permanentes. Euh je lisais je j'avais
une discussion récemment avec quelqu'un
qui ou non, j'avais vu ça sur Twitter,
je trouvais ça vachement intéressant.
C'était une une jeune femme qui disait
"Oui euh quelqu'un hier un mec m'a dit
"Oui euh c'est fou les femmes, vous
pouvez multitasquer, vous pensez à plein
de trucs en même temps, c'est génial,
c'est c'est un don." Et là, elle lui a
répondu "Non, en fait, c'est pas un don,
c'est une malédiction, c'est juste que
c'est ça s'appelle la charge mentale.
C'est que les femmes doivent et sont
assignées par la société à penser à
plein de trucs en même temps." Et elle
me dit, "Je l'ai foutu mal à l'aise, ça
me va." Et je pense que en tant que mec,
en tant que blanc, en tant que 6, il
faut que j'accepte aussi un moment
d'être mal à l'aise parce qu'en fait les
personnes qui sont en face, cette
violence-là, c'est généralement celle de
la société en général. Tel qu'
Pourquoi mettre les gens mal à laissé ?
C'est pour leur faire comprendre.
Mais parce que je peux pas être noir.
Donc je comprendrai jamais. S'il y a pas
un moment où elle me confronte aux
limites de du système, comment je fais
pour comprendre moi ce que c'est que
d'être noir ? Je peux pas. Donc c'est
normal qu'il me foutent mal à l'aise à
un moment. C'est normal que des meufs me
mettent malaise un moment. C'est normal
que des personnes trans me mettent
malaise. Je sais pas ce que c'est. Je
pourrais jamais le savoir. Donc cette
expérience, le malaise qu'on expéri
Ouais. Bah tu es un homme blanc 6.
Voilà. Mais don non mais c'est
parce que à l'intérieur je suis noir.
Mais justement tu ne pourras jamais
l'être. C'est ça le truc. Et ce que je
veux dire c'est que la violence
systémique que fait exprès l'avocat du
diable, je te coupe exprès.
Mais la la violence systémique que
subissent ces personnesl moi je pourrais
jamais expérimenter sur plein de
dimensions. Je suis valide. Je suis
valide, je fais du vélo et tout. Il y a
plein de gens qui pourront jamais en
faire pour leur raison. Je pourrais
jamais savoir ce que c'est. Tes
cicatrices sont intérieures.
Non, non, pas du tout. Non, mais j'ai
je veux pas je veux pas je veux je veux
pas je veux pas paraître trop sérieux ou
trop premier degré mais c'est juste
cette idée là, c'est que ce malaise
comparé à ce que vivent comme violence
systémique ces personnes-là, c'est
peinuts, c'est que dalle. Et quelque
part, vivre ce malaise et accepter de
vivre ce malaise, c'est aussi à un
moment reconnaître que bah il y a des
expériences que tu pourras pas faire. et
c'est intégrer aussi un petit peu bah
ces différences de vécu dans la société.
Pour revenir aux communautés qui se qui
deviennent plus agressives, d'autres
d'autres retours à nous faire
remonter
d'autres d'autres communautés qui
retour Oui.
Non non mais en fait c'est il y en a
d'autres. Oui. Il y a les
les éthétésiciens qui nous ont un peu
fait chier parce que parce que eux ils
vénèrent non pas un dieu mais la
science. Donc la science, ce serait
l'unique et seule et unique réponse à
l'intégralité de de toutes les questions
qui se posent aujourd'hui au genre
humain et à Vitam eternam oubliant qu'il
y a des facteurs sociaux là aussi
politiques, économique, historique.
Grosso modo en fait alors qu'il y a
aussi une une historicité de la science
des gens qui étudient ça. Merde
Galilé Galilée rappelle bien.
Oui enfin a un dieu c'est Galilée puis
voilà tout quoi. Puis on mais on adore
un autre dieu mais finalement d'adorer
la science comme adorer Galilée ou
adorer Saint-Pierre c'est adorer
quelqu'un donc c'est planté quoi.
J'adore personne et c'est et c'est et
c'est et c'est éviter la complexité.
C'est que finalement c'est que tous ceux
qu'on se qu'on se prend en pleine poire
euh à intervalle régulier de différentes
des différents groupes sont des gens qui
qui refusent finalement de prendre en
compte le fait que tout est construction
et multifactoriel et extrêmement
complexe ou
et qu'avoir un avis tranché et définitif
surtout bah c'est impossible sauf à être
éventuellement Dieu parce que l'objectif
est possible c'est l'objectivité c'est
Dieu. Non moi personnellement j'y crois
pas mais j'aimerais bien. Je suis
agnostique j'en sais rien tu vois. Je je
aposta. Non, tu es pasta.
Je suis pas non, je suis pas aposta. Je
suis pas mais non, mais je respecte
vachement l'idée de la foi. Je trouve ça
vachement intéressant dès lors que tu
emmerdes personne avec ça. Tu vois, si
tu crois si tu crois en c'est possible,
c'est une manière de d'être en rapport
au monde et aux questions
existentielles, pourquoi pas ? Très
bien. J'ai pas j'ai pas ce
posta
euh Oui, un post mais c'est
fier de l'être.
Fier mais en même temps respectueux de
de des spiritualités. Moi, j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses auprès bah
typiquement des mouvements notamment des
mouvements monastiques, les Bénédictins,
la règle de Saint-Benoît, c'est vraiment
une lecture que je recommande à beaucoup
de gens. J'ai lu durant mes chères
études en histoire à la Sorbonne des
vies de seins, des agéographies.
Martin, tu connais ? Je connais moi. Moi
mon ma
Saül
la référence pour moi c'est plutôt la
vie d' la vie d'Antoine de Saint-Jean
Christostom euh Saint-Antoine Perd des
moines. Voilà, ça c'est des choses. Mais
je trouve que quand je lis la vie
d'Antoine,
c'est littérairement et en terme de de
pensée l'une des représentations les
plus puissantes que j'ai eu de ce qu'est
le mal en fait. Et je trouve que les
religions ont servi pendant des siècles
à penser le mal, la mort et cetera. Donc
pour moi, tout n'est pas acheté. La
Bible est un est un fondement culturel
comme la Torah, comme enfin tous les
textes sacrés sont des fondements
culturels, les Veda, le Coran. Donc les
lire, c'est aussi aller aux sources de
représentation du monde
et puis de notre monde aussi. on est
constitué par ces liv
notre culture. Enfin, tu peux pas tu
peux pas te balader dans les rues et
ignorer que ce monde a été construit en
grande partie sur des croyances que nous
ne partageons pas forcément, mais
et et une synthèse aussi de croyances
antérieures. Euh donc c'est c'est la des
un instant où l'humanité se rejoint euh
et des des
dans la croyance,
non dans dans dans le livre, dans les
dans les écrits qu'il faut qu'il faut il
faut respecter et et lire avec attention
parce que c'est passionnant. Et en
parlant de fois, je voulais revenir sur
la loi Avia euh puisque pour moi, la loi
Avia repose précisément sur un dogme qui
est le dogme de l'autorégulation parce
que euh en gros alors pour je sais pas
du coup le niveau de de de d'information
de ta communauté là-dessus, mais la loi
Avia prévoit notamment tout un système
de sanctions en cas de publication de
contenu qui enfraindrait un certain
nombre de principes autour au jug la
police peut effectivement sanctionner.
Voilà. Donc il y a donc sans recours au
juges donc l'état de droit là. Et en
fait surtout le truc important c'est on
demande de manière implicite dans la loi
Avia aux plateformes de se démerder.
Alors d'un côté on pourrait dire oh là
là dis donc c'est pas gentil. Mais de
l'autre côté, ça repose quand même sur
l'idée que bah les plateformes, elles
vont devoir un peu faire ça par
elles-même. Elles vont devoir faire le
ménage par elles-même. Moi, ça m'a
beaucoup fait penser à la à lo de Devoir
de vigilance qui avait été voté suite à
l'effondrement de l'usine du Ranap Plaza
au Bangladesh et où en gros on avait dit
"Oh là là, on a trouvé des t-shirts H&M
dans les ruines au côté de quelques
cadavres. On a trouvé des t-shirts hm
dans les ruines. Maintenant, il faut
vraiment que les entreprises, elles
arrêtent de de prendre des
sous-traitants et de pas assumer leur
responsabilité. Ça suffit maintenant.
Alors, ce qu'on va faire, c'est que les
entreprises, vous allez faire des
rapports
par vous-même,
vous nous les envoyez et voilà. Et donc
concrètement, bah tu as pas de contrôle
derrière, tu as pas d'organe de
contrôle. C'est pas prévu dans la loi,
il y a rien pour les saisir. Là, c'est
pareil. La loi vient et dit
"Démerdez-vous avec la gestion de la de
la violence verbale, du du sexisme, de
l'homophobie et cetera sur internet. Euh
et puis si jamais vous le faites mal, et
ben on vous tape sur la gueule." Alors,
résultat des cours, ça a été déjà
observé par quelques journalistes. Je
crois qu'il y a un article qui est paru
dans le monde récemment. Et ben
concrètement, tu as plein de propos de
personnes LGBT par exemple de comptes de
personnes LGBT qui ont été suspendus sur
des réseaux sociaux parce que faudrait
faire gaffe, tu vois, des fois qu'elles
disent des conneries. C'est un peu la
même chose qui se passe avec YouTube où
tu as une espèce d'assimilation où on a
peur de choquer certaines personnes.
YouTube c'est pour une autre raison.
C'est parce queon a peur que les
annonceurs soient pas contents de
certains trucs. C'est comme ça que plein
de youtubeuses peuvent plus parler de
règles par exemple ou de viol parce que
c'est le sexe, tu vois. Alors que à côté
tu as des propos mascul et qui passent
comme ça tranquille parce que c'est pas
le sexe.
C'est quoi un propos mascul ?
Masculiniste euh
ça veut dire quoi ? Bah dans le sens de
euh de propos euh qui euh rabaissent les
femmes, qui objectifie les femmes, qui
enfin voilà euh si on se bat sur
YouTube, je pense que tu trouves assez
facilement des choses qui par leur façon
de présenter les femmes, par leur façon
de présenter le propos des femmes, de
les critiquer, de les réduire à un
statut d'infériorité parce que femme, de
les minorer relève de ça. Mais par
contre, une meuf qui va parler de viol,
une femme qui va parler de viol, euh une
youtubeuse, on va la censurer parce que
euh le viol c'est du sexe et le sexe
c'est sale et les annonceurs, ils aiment
pas quand c'est sale. est pareil pour
les règles. Les règles, ça
on va la censurer. On va pas lui donner
de l'argent de la pub.
Alors, on va pardon, tu as raison. On va
la démonétiser.
My bad, my bad. On va démonétiser.
Et pour certaines, ça ça les empêche de
vivre effectivement dans certaines voilà
c'est un c'est une différence de
traitement
et d'expression. Et du coup là, la loi
Avia, elle dit bah en faites gaffe si
vous faites des conneries. Donc ce que
font les plateformes très logiquement
c'est que pour pas se faire taper sur la
gueule parce que les sanctions peuvent
être financièrement très très élevées
euh
euh pour pas se faire taper sur la
gueule, elles font du préventif. Et le
préventif c'est quoi ? Bah c'est plutôt
dans l'ordre de l'ensure.
Tu veux rebondir sur laavia ?
Pas du tout.
Alors je me fais encore un peu l'avoqué
du diable. Euh euh des docings de gens
sur internet, euh les révélations de X
ou Y sur leur vie privée, le les
insulter de tous les noms, leur prêter
des relations qu'ils n'ont pas, leur
leur en mettre plein la tête à longueur
de journée, du cyberharcèlement en
communauté.
avec machin qui rebondit, qui partage
sur sa communauté pour recharger la Vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ? C'estement
en fait hein. Ouais. Oui.
Ça on l'a tous subi ici non ?
Plus ou moins. Ouais.
Ah bah beaucoup moins que la plupart des
femmes et des personnes racisées.
Un peu mais pas ça m'a pas traumatisé.
traumatis non mais qu'il faille faire
quelque chose contre ça éventuellement
ou bien sûr on dire
parce que si vous êtes pas à cœur que
vous avez pas la capacité de tracer l'IP
vous avez pas un copain qui travaille
chez Twitter qui peut vous filer les IP
des gars que vous avez pas un copain
chez Facebook qui travaille en Irlande
qui peut vous filer les accès des
comptes
dans l'illégalité un problème et c'est
pas la solution ah de quoi que nous on
soit capable d'aller chercher les gars
parce qu'on a des copains qui
travaillent à Facebook Irlande qu'on a
des copains qui travaillent chez Twitter
qui sont payés au lance-pierre et qu'on
marre de se faire payer au lance-pierre
et que ils connaissent, ils nous
connaissent, on les appelle, on leur dit
"Écoute mec, lui lui, je veux savoir, je
veux que tu m'aides à cartographier sa
nébuleuse, ainsi de suite."
Hm.
Oui, bien sûr.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
C'est pas la loi Aire, en tout cas autre
chose. C'est compliqué. Euh et
et aussi qui n'a pas un avocat qui est
blindé ?
Un avocat, hein. Un avocat pour aller
chercher les IP. C'est pas beau ça.
Est-ce que c'est pas beau ? Si si, si
si. Mais là, tu es costaud dans ces
cas-là. Mais tout le monde n'est pas
aussi costaud que que certains non,
moi je suis rancunier
et ma grand-mère m'a toujours expliqué
assis-toi sur le bord du pont, tu verras
le cadavre de ton ami passé. T'inquiète
pas,
t'inquiète pas, ça va bien se passer.
Non, en tout cas, il faut réagir certes,
mais je pense que c'est c'est un face à
un problème aussi complexe, cette loi
aussi baclée, aussi bête et n' n'a pas
n'a pas n'a aucun sens, quoi. Voilà.
Mais juste pour rebondir euh
parce que juste un truc quand pour
parcourir la loi et l'avoir parcouru à
Chouya, mais c'est ni fait ni affaire,
c'est mal écrit, c'est mal pensé, c'est
mal réfléchi, c'est vraiment c'est du
copier-collé de fausses solutions
pondues sur les blogs à gauche et à
droite. C'est n'importe quoi. Donc non
seulement euh ils sont chelous mais en
plus ils bossent pas. Tu vois, il y a de
l'incompétence quoi.
Juste, tu as tout à fait raison, il y a
des choses à faire. Moi, j'ai pas la
réponse, je pas arrivé en prétendant.
Par contre, il y a quelque chose qui est
clair, c'est que l'une des premières
façons de réfléchir au aux questions,
c'est pas d'arriver et de lâcher, ça
fait un an qu'elle est en débat la loi
vient, euh de pas d'arriver et de lâcher
comme ça une espèce de bombe solution
passe partout qui repose sur la bonne
foi des gens. C'est juste de demander
aux personnes qui se font doxer, aux
personnes qui sont harcelées, genre
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez faire doxer
façon 39 45 quand même.
Non mais violent bien sûr. Qu'est-ce que
de quoi vous auriez besoin ? Et en fait
la vraie
dox, ça veut dire quoi
donc ça ? du enfin se faire
cyberharceler attends se faire cibler
par par
faire se faire révéler
tu révé la communauté et cetera mais
c'est l'un des points du
cyberharcèlement mais juste un truc
quand même pardon sur je t'interromps 15
secondes mais sur ces ces ces ces
stratégies collectives avec des bottes
avec effectivement de la révélation
d'identité ou d'adresse ou
c'est c'est organisé par majoritairement
des groupesuscules politiques très
organisés très identifiés On sait qui
ils sont, on connaît leur adresse
toujours.
Parmi ces gens-là, pardon, parmi ces
gens-là, il y a des partis politiques
qui sont au pouvoir
ou des puissances étrangères
ou des puissances étrangères. Mais que
les les les botes de la RM, on les
connaît, on les identifié, ils sont
identifiés et c'est pas par moi, par les
gens du monde, tu vois, pas par les plus
révolutionnaires, c'est pas BTAMAG,
c'est les décleurs du monde. Ils ont
identifié les botes de la REM qui fait
qui qui qui produisent mécaniquement,
c'est leur fonction, le leur raison
d'être, de du cyberharcèlement
politique. Donc qui viennent pas nous
faire la leçon en faisant une en donnant
plein pouvoir à la police pour régler le
problème.
Question de la communauté, je l'attrape
au au vol. Que pens-il ? Vas-y, je t'en
prie.
Je voulais terminer une réponse, je t'ai
coupé, excuse-moi. Non, non, c'est juste
c'est juste pour revenir à ça, tu as
raison. C'est un fait société qui cause
énormément de dégâts, y compris
psychologique à plein de gens. Et en
fait, il y a juste un truc tout bête,
c'est que si on pouvait déjà faire des
auditions avec ces personnes-là, avec
des associations typiquement va enfin va
dans les associations LGBT. Cette
question là, elle est ramenée
régulièrement et c'est un phénomène de
société à très large échelle. Juste si
on demandait il y a il y a des réponses
qui existent déjà et des réflexions qui
sont déjà menées dans des organisations.
Mais ces gens-là, on les consulte pas.
Ça c'est un peu de démocratie de parler
au concerné. Et typiquement l'accès aux
droits, genre typ Ouais. pas avoir
besoin d'un avocat, pas avoir peur que
tu es des flics qui rient doucement à ta
plainte. Quoi vous vous êtes fait
emmerder sur Twitter ? Écoutez, on a
d'autres choses à faire en fait. Il y a
des gens qui font se font voler leur
sac. Euh tu vois juste ça, un meilleur
accueil de ces des victimes déjà serait
probablement une des solutions. Et les
autres, je pense que sincèrement les
personnes qui se font doxé, elles
pourraient le dire si on les écoutait un
petit peu mais on les écoute pas.
Et si elles se feront justice toutes
seules ces personnes qui se sont doxées,
c'est bien, c'est pas bien ?
C'est compliqué là. Tu parles autre
chose. Chaud.
Non non, c'est compliqué.
C'est chaud. Puissz les mettre en
anglais.
Chaud répondra à ça. Chaos répondra à ça
comme ça en général. Pas le conseiller.
Je conseille pas. Je pose une question.
Je veux pas parler de général.
C'est compliqué. C'est compliqué.
Alors question d'internet. Que
pensent-t-il de l'électronisme ambiant
chez nos politiques ainsi que de
l'astroturfing en cours ? Waouh
! L'électronisme quoi, c'est le recours
à stop Covid et cetera ou c'est espèce
de
alors l'électronisme.
L'électronisme
c'est le solutionnisme la technophilie.
Solutionnisme technologique. Ouais.
Bon
on on parlera du traçage après on parla
de
D'accord.
Donc l'astro turfing.
C'est quoi l'astrurfing ? Moi je suis
complètement opé. C'est c'est des
conneries ou pas ? Non. C'est quoi
l'astrurfing ? C'est le fait d'organiser
de manière artificielle une
manifestation avec beaucoup de comptes
desfin de créer en fait un faux effet de
soulèvement. Pas mal, tu es presque par
par la mobilisation de de cont
manipuler manipuler l'opinion publique
en en exactement en en en faisant monter
des tendances comme ça
grâce au botes et cetera.
Oui. Oui. Au bot ou à d'autres d'autres
recours d'autres bah c'est de la
manipulation là. C'est c'est c'est
défint. C'est un peu ce qui s'est passé
avec al on schématise à l'extrême mais
c'est Cambridge Genaltica, c'est la
manipulation
euh c'est c'est des deux big data avec
la collègue grâce aux collègues de
données personnelles et cetera. C'est un
vrai problème bien sûr. Enfin euh c'est
compliqué ça menace ça menace
je préfère de mon démocrate à de balles
mais la démocratie au sens premier du
terme réelle c'est elle qui consiste à
écouter l'autre à prendre encore une
fois le en compte la complexité des
opinions et des solutions. Enfin voilà
c'est c'est
Alors il y a une proposition de loi pour
empêcher le fait qu'on filme les flics.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Conneries c'est pas possible.
Comment on fait ? Enfin je dire donc du
coup on documente pas les Pourquoi on
fait ça ? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi tu le
filmes pas ? Tu filmes quoi ? pas quand
quand il est sympa ou quand il tap sur
quel c'est quoi l'objectif c'est quoi en
réalité ?
C'est quoi l'exception ?
Ah bah aucune idée je suis pas des
Mais non mais c'est absurde. On sent
bien on sent bien que cette c'est une
proposition de loi qui vient de de
Siotti Bon voilà tout est dit quoi.
Proposition loi d'Coti
le sujet est clos. Non mais voilà
tu as le droit de ne pas aimer Eric.
C'est pas ça c'est que j'aime pas ses
idées. Moi lui je sais je le connais
pas. Je sais pas c'est peut-être un mec
adorable avec table il est rigolo mais
sa profession loi est ridicule. Ça a pas
de sens. Ridicule non elle est
liberticide. C'estàd que si tu peux pas
contrôler euh avec les outils qui sont
les nôtres sur les citoyennes et les
citoyens euh la manière dont les les
policiers traitent euh euh les citoyens
et les citoyens, bah c'est c'est un
problème. On sent bien que c'est pour
euh permettre des violences policières
qui se produisent tous les jours.
Bon là là on a sauté de sujet en sujet
en pointiller et ainsi de suite. La la
question initiale c'est comment vous
sentez l'avenir proche ? Est-ce que pour
vous ça sent le sapin ou ça sent pas le
sapin ? Ça sent la positivité ?
Non, j'ai du mal avec avec la de
positivité en fait.
Je me fais ségoline royal,
j'entends. Non mais pour moi pour moi
l'idée de l'idée enfin déjà c'est pas ça
sent sapin, ça sent jamais le sapin ça
jamais. Enfin, je veux dire pour moi le
sapin de qui tu vois parce qu'il y a un
moment où faut que tu mettes quelqu'un
dans la boîte quoi.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de du mouvement
la collapsologie ?
Bah pour moi, la collapsologie a fait
beaucoup de mal à l'écologie politique
dans l'acception qui est celle que moi
je considère comme légitime,
c'est-à-dire la pensée une pensée
globale et transversale des
problématiques qui lient l'homme à son
environnement, l'humanité à son
environnement. Donc pour moi l'écologie,
ça va être la réintégration de
l'humanité dans son environnement. C'est
l'âge adulte. C'est le moment où tu dis
"Ah bah en fait mes actes ont des
conséquences pas seulement sur moi, pas
seulement sur mes proches, pas seulement
sur mais sur la globalité, sur une forme
de globalité. Et la collapsologie, c'est
un peu le côté du style "Ah [__] on a
merdé ça va se péter la gueule mais
après ce sera trop cool, on aura table
rase." Alors non, en fait, zéro table
rase. Et d'autre part, la collapsologie,
c'est un luxe, en fait, c'est aussi un
luxe. C'estd que va au va au Burkina va
à Owaga qu'a
à Mada bon on en parlons même pas mais
va à Ouaga va à Ouaga et et va dire à
Ouadougu au Burkfaso va leur dire il y a
un problème de plastique
dans les environs de wag tu as tellement
de sacs en plastique que les plantes ne
poussent plus parce que c'est la seule
chose qui résiste au milieu du désert tu
as des gens qui crèvent la dalle des des
agriculteurs qui peuvent plus river à
cause des sachets comme on dit à cause
des sacs en plastique. Le plastique
là-bas c'est c'est c'est un enfer. Et
pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a des on n' pas
amené là-bas les solutions nécessaires.
On a exporté toutes ces merdes et
malheureusement la plupart de ces
régimes politiques et de ces systèmes
économique n'avait pas de le choix que
de les accepter. La collapsologie
là-bas, ils ont pas le luxe de la
collapsologie. Ils disent juste on on on
essaie de survivre. Et cette espèce
d'idée de de qui est une forme de
victimisation de dire "Oh là là dis donc
nous les occidentaux oh c'est pas facile
en ce moment mais [__] mais
bougez-vous le cul aller voir ailleurs
je serais moins dur je serai moins dur
moi avec la tu peux sois si tu veux mais
là aussi je pense qu'on est dans une s
de binarisation c'estd que le le le
discours des collapsologues ceux qui
évoquent l'effondrement il y a des gens
vachement intéressants qui disent des
trucs vraiment moi qui m' qui
m'informment de plein de choses j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il qu'il fige le débat
c'est un mouvement il pointe un risque à
court terme effectivement en occident
bien sûr. Moi, j'ai tourné il y a
quelques temps à Madagascar sur les
travailleurs du clip. J'ai traversé la
la la RN RN7 sur 500 km. Bah,
l'effondrement, il a lieu là-bas, c'est
faitin. Tu as plus un arbre, c'est
l'enfer. Tu as des horses de population
qui vivent dans un état de misère mais
absolu. L'État est totalement absent. Il
y a pas de médecine. Bon, c'est les
fondaments, c'est là-bas. Bon, ça que
que que soit qu'il soit systémique et
total et global et mondiale, c'est
effectivement une possibilité. Moi, je
pense que c'est une manière euh pour
ceux qui évoquent l'effondrement.
d'interroger ce qui se produit ici aussi
ça ça doit pas ça doit pas démotiver et
interrompre un processus de réflexion
d'analyse et de transformation ça doit
l'initier et si ça l'initie c'est très
bien c'est une stratégie finalement de
rapportité mais on va pas faire un débat
sur la collapseologie que je sentais que
tu allais là
non mais je suis pas je je je juste de
mon droit de pas être d'accord
mais très bien d'accord plus je pense
que c'est c'est une manière de pointer
du doigt couper tu viens de le couper
et été très long précédemment c'est pour
ça que je je
fait
tellement gratuit, je vois même pas pour
ça. Euh non mais moi ce qui me gêne en
fait pour la collapsologie, c'est la
tendance de ce mouvement de pensée. Je
dis pas qu'il y a que du mauvais hein,
je dis juste que globalement quand même,
il y a ce côté une entrée facile dans
l'écologie au travers la catastrophe. Et
penser la catastrophe, ce n'est pas
penser l'effondrement. C'est deux choses
très très très différentes. Si tu penses
que on est en ce moment parce que il y a
cette idée en fait ce qui me fait chier
dans la collapsologie c'est cette idée
précisément de chute. Moi je vois pas la
chute le moment où ça va s'arrêter. Le
shutdown j'y crois pas. Et pour le coup
on a un peu travaillé sur la question
pour un épisode à venir notamment sur
une question énergétique.
Il va pas avoir une coupure
d'électricité généralisée comme on le
voit dans certains films de
science-fiction. Nos systèmes sont pas
faits pour ça. Il va y avoir plein de
conneries. Mais sauf qu'en fait ces
coupures de courant là, elles disent
quelque chose dans notre société, elles
disent quelque chose dans notre système,
elles montrent qu'on est arrivé à une
phase de sursaturation. Et il y a un
moment en fait ce qui va se passer,
c'est que bah progressivement les
personnes les plus fragiles vont en
prendre plein la gueule et on vont plus
avoir accès à ce niveau de vie qu'on
prétend universel jaune
par exemple. Mais pour moi, le seul sens
de l'effondrement, c'est pas un
effondrement genre blam, c'est tac tac
tac tac, ça va, c'est un tassement. Il y
a un tassement et le et les premières
personnes qui sont écrasées par le
tassement, c'est qui sont tout en bas,
elles sont à Madagascar et c'est pas
celles qui font un discours sur la
collapsologie. C'est en ça que je suis
critique de cette façon d'envisager la
crise écologique. C'est qui l'envisage
comme ça ?
Par de serving, tu parles de
Ouais, c'était Non, mais c'est
en fait c'est un récit. Juste un truc,
j'aimerais parce que je pense qu'ils
sont pas ils sont pas ils proposent pas
une solution. Pas que ça va se casser la
gueule d'un coup hein.
Mais non non, c'est bien plus compliqué
que ça en fait. C'estàd que c'est une
manière aussi de construire un récit qui
qui nous permet d'entrer dans l'écologie
et et de de finalement de et et cette
construction de récit est essentielle
pour des prises de conscience. Donc ça
joue son son rôle. En revanche
effectivement
euh Stop Pierre c'est ça c'est les c'est
les derniers wagons avec les les les 100
billets qui vont être largués au fur et
à mesure. Ils le sont déjà ils le sont
déjà en Afrique, ils sont déjà dans
l'Asie du Sud-Est. Ils sont déjà dans
des quartiers trèspau dans les favellas
de l'Amérique du Sud. C'est déjà le cas
en fait. Ça c'est pas c'est pas morce.
Combien vous gagnez ?
Pardon ?
Ça dépend des mois puisque je suis
interctacles.
Ça dépend des mois.
Euh je dois être en moyenne.
Moi j'ai un salaire fixe dans une la
scope dans laquelle je bosse de 1600
balles et à côté de ça avec data gul bah
ça dépend des mois. Euh c'est l'ordre de
800 € sur en plus avec data gueule.
Voilà
par mois. Moi je dois gagner entre si je
tourne pas du tout zéro. Si je tourne
beaucoup 3 à 4000 parfois 5 euh voilà
c'est c'est je suis un intermittent du
spectacle mais je je suis j'ai
conscience
d'être du bon côté de la barrière dire
que je je suis un anti euh voilà en un
seul mot
on va on va parler perspective d'avenir.
Euh vous êtes sur un un projet
documentaire c'est ça ? de séries
documentaires
de séries documentaires en plusieurs
épisodes
euh concernant les utopies. Alors, ma
première question avant de rentrer dans
le détail de de l'utopie, c'est quoi une
utopie pour vous ?
Alors, pour nous, c'est quoi
historiquement euh
euh non, historiquement a Thomas Mour
qui parle effectivement d'un lieu qui
n'existe pas encore, une sorte de lieu
idéal. Voilà.
Mais mais par voie de transformation
pour nous, pour moi à l'instant, ne
parlons pas de nous, parlons de moi. mon
point de vue essentiel, c'est c'est le
le ce qu'il y a après le soulèvement,
c'est que tu ce que tu peux construire
en essayant d'être le plus aligné
possible, le plus en accord possible
avec ce que tu crois juste, pertinent
face aujourd'hui dans un un contexte
très très particulier parce que j'ai
beau être un du bon côté de la barrière
aujourd'hui, on est quand même je suis
aussi un homo sapience, j'ai notre
espèce est soumise à des des urgences
très collectives qui sont les urgences
psychologiques. C'est vrai que là en
l'occurrence, effondrement ou pas, je
sais pas ce que ça va provoquer mais euh
à quelques dans quelques dizaines
d'années voir voire moins, on va avoir
de et on a déjà des sérieux problèmes de
de réchauffement climatique, de
bouleversement climatique, c'est pas que
le réchauffement euh de crises sociales
et sanitaires, on l'a vu récemment et
que tout ça se donc il y a il y a une
urgence vitale, des urgences vitales qui
menacent notre notre espèce ainsi que
les autres espèces gén d'homos sapiens,
c'est que on va pas entraîner fondrement
ou non, mais la 6e extinction de masse,
elle est possible dans le fruit le fruit
de l'entreposine, c'est la fin de
l'entreposine
et on va emmener avec nous quelques
milliers d'espèces comme ça très
collectif, l'arge de Noé qui coule, tu
vois, c'est sympa. Donc effectivement
l'utopie l'utopie c'est c'est tu tuas
l'occasion de le dire l'utopie c'est le
lieu. C'est important dans ta gueule qui
a des débat ça nourrit aussi la
complexité de nos récits. C'est c'est le
lieu à construire de toute urgence pour
qu'on arrête ce train fou en marche.
Alors avant avant de passer la parole à
Sylvain dans le début de ta phrase tu as
dit après le soulèvement.
Non, le soulèvement individuel,
personnel, je crois pas je crois pas une
révolution mondiale le grand soir. Tout
d'un coup, l'ensemble des peuple de du
monde vont vont se dresser ne faire
qu'un pour bâtir une société géniale. Je
crois pas du tout à ça. Malheureusement,
j'y crois pas. Je crois que le 20e
siècle nous a montré que les solutions
hégémoniques, les idéologies totalites
ou totales en tout cas ne fonctionnent
pas. Ce sont des et et produisent
mécaniquement d'autres principes de
domination. C'est les apparachies qui
finissent par dominer. euh et plus la
bourgeoisie ou plus euh euh les Aristos.
Donc euh non, je parle du soulèvement
personnel. Tout d'un coup, c'est c'est
c'est de se dire "Bah finalement, je je
me redresse, je ne je ne me je me
conforme plus à l'ordre établi. On nous
dit pourquoi on croit pas aux utopies ?
Pourquoi dans dans le mot utopie, on
entend spontanément
doux rêve réservé à des dou rêveurs.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit ? Ça dit que il y a
le réel, le réel qui est incontournable.
Donc ce monde là, ce monde qui qui court
à sa perte, mais ce monde-là est
l'unique voie possible. Ce serait le
fruit naturel de l'évolution organique
de notre espèce. Et il y a pas d'autres
échappatoire. C'est totalement connaître
le fait que Homo sapiens depuis 300000
ans voir davantage nous sommes sur terre
on a expérimenté des dizaines de
milliers d'organisations sociale
différente. C'est une construction notre
monde. C'est une construction qui
déconne. Donc on peut se soulever contre
cet ordre établi en disant non c'est pas
le fruit naturel des choses. C'est pas
l'ordre naturel et incontournable auquel
il faut impérativement se soumettre. On
peut faire autrement. Et se soulever
c'est décider de faire autrement. seul à
5 à 10 à 30 à quelques millions comme
dans la rojava quelque condition que ce
soit parce que une fois les conditions
sont pas réunies on va dire ça aucurde
dans les ades absolument tous ceux qui
tout à coup dis on va faire autrement on
fait ses session on est ça marche pas
c'estieux là
au sens du terme je je je j'interromps
cette ce rapport de soumission
d'acceptation de règles de règles du jeu
que je considère comme problématiqu
Voilà. Et c'est ça l'utopie.
Sylvin.
Euh alors, j'aurais une réponse en deux
parties. La première, c'est pour
reprendre la référence de d'Henry. Donc
déjà, l'utopie, c'est un mot qui est
inventé par Thomas Mor. Et en fait,
l'utopie, donc c'est soit le lieu qui
n'existe pas, soit le bon lieu. Et la
lecture un peu fausse ou qui est dans
l'erreur de Thomas Mo et de l'utopie,
c'est de dire bah finalement le
l'utopie, les îles d'utopie,
c'est un endroit qui n'existe pas. En
fait, si c'est un droit qui existe,
c'est juste l'inverse de l'Angleterre.
Et c'est pour moi le premier point de
départ, c'est que l'utopie c'est une
critique du temps présent. Toujours
toutes les utopies ont été des critiques
de du temps présent. Euh les utopies
n'allaient pas dans le sens euh du
régime politique en place, de l'ordre
des mœurs et cetera. Les utopies étaient
toujours des contradictions. Donc il y a
cette vertu de contredire. Et la
deuxième partie, c'est pour moi l'utopie
en fait, un peu comme démocratie qu'on a
qu'on a érigé comme un système. Alors
qu'en fait on a on a pris conscience
dans ce document, dans le précédent
documentaire que c'était plus un
mouvement, qu'il y avait des
institutions démocratiques mais que la
démocratie n'était pas une espèce de de
de notice IKEA, des trucs qu'il fallait
absembler pour faire démocratie. Faire
démocratie, ça existe. C'est un
mouvement. L'utopie, c'est pareil. Il y
a des mouvements utopiques, il y a une
démarche utopique et ça me fait penser à
à quelqu'un dont j'aime beaucoup les
écrits qui est David Greber qui est
notamment l'une des chevilles ouvrières
de Occupai Wall Street et qui pour
résumer son son sa démarche et son
expérience sur Occupai avait écrit un
bouquin dont le titre est un programme,
c'est comme si nous étions déjà libres.
Et euh le ce qu'il anime, lui c'est un
c'est un anarchiste
de cœur et de pratique. Euh et ce qu'il
anime, c'est se dire finalement si dans
notre petit embryon de société là et de
contestation, on se comporte comme le
système que nous contestons nous-mêmes,
on ne vaut pas mieux que le système que
nous contestons nous-mêmes et nous ne
faisons rien avancer ni nous-même ni le
système. Donc au moins que à cette toute
petite échelle qui était Zuketi Park qui
est vraiment pas grand-chose. On parlait
tout à l'heure de la Rojava de de la
Belgique et là on parle de de quelques
même pas quelques petits hectares au
milieu de New York de Manattan. C'est
cette idée de si là on se comporte déjà
comme on voudrait que le monde marche,
alors on fait un peu avancer le monde.
Et pour moi c'est ça l'utopie. Quel que
soit encore une fois l'échelle, euh
l'utopie, c'est parfois certaines
personnes qui vont s'isoler. On a fait
une interview euh super intéressante,
encore une fois, je parlais des moines
tout à l'heure. Euh bah le l'isolement,
le le départ au désert, c'est une forme
d'utopie. S'arracher de l'autorité du
prince, de l'évêque. C'est une forme
d'utopie. De recréer dans un système
quelque chose qui ressemblerait au monde
qu'on espère. En l'occurrence, ce que
les moyens espéraitent c'était le
royaume de Dieu, mais c'était le cré sur
terre. Les ades c'est autre chose. Les
ades ont tenté de fonctionner comme
comme elles voudrait que ce soit du
diable.
Je t'en prie. Mais Daesh, c'est pas une
utopie Daesh,
une dystopie plutôt
c'est une dystopie parce qu'en fait le
monde selon Dieu dans
dans l'utopie dans l'utopie il y a quand
même l'idée de l'émancipation
et que chacun l'émancipation
individuelle, pas celle qui est décidée
par quelques-uns en haut, qu'il soit Mao
ou Staline pour le bien de tous et qui
redescendrait qui ruissolerait qui
ruissellerait comme l'argent ruisselle
dans le libéralisme.
une émancipation délibérée réelle et et
individuelle et donc je pense que Daesh
ne cav pas
m'émanciper des coufars.
Oui mais que tu tu vas pas tuer ceux qui
sont pas coufars.
Dans ce cas-là, si c'est le cas, c'est
problématique. C'est que là tu tu tu
n'es plus un utopiste. Tu es un tu es un
prosélite sectaire, dogmatique et et
meurtrier.
Donc cette scène n'a strictement rien à
voir. L'utopie effectivement on est dans
dans une forme d'idéal et idéal encore
une fois ne veut pas dire irréel. Euh
c'est qu'il y a quelque chose de de qui
qui permet de d'aligner d'aligner euh
des valeurs finalement relativement
simples, hein, de respect de l'autre,
euh de respect de soi, de partage, de
justice, euh d'équité, euh d'égalité.
C'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
extraordinaire comme comme enfin c'est
des concepts assez simples et qui me
semblent relativement légitimes.
C'est un peu la France que tu es en
train de me décrire là.
Pas tout à fait. Non, pas tout à fait
parce que enfin la France telle qu'elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui avec un Bernard
Arnaud et des gilets jaunes et borniers,
je suis pas certain.
Tu tu peux tu peux retourner le truc.
Pour moi, l'utopie c'est confronter
l'idéal à la réalité. Alors que la là là
l'idée c'est que on confronte la réalité
à l'idéal de l'autre côté. C'est que
concrètement tu as des gust qui nous
expliquent alors en fait la devise sur
le fronton là on va essayer de le faire
dans la mesure du possible. Les
utopistes c'est l'inverse. Ils disent
alors en fait le le la mesure du
possible on va essayer de la repousser
au nom de ce qui est écrit sur le
fronton. C'est ça la différence, c'est
que c'est des gens qui au lieu d'arriver
en disant alors il y a la merde donc on
va tenter de maintenir l'égalité autant
que possible et tu as des personnes qui
arrivent qui en disant alors c'est la
merde donc on va créer un endroit on va
chercher une brèche pour reprendre cette
belle expression de Michel Rio Sars on a
interview une historienne fantastique
dans son engagement pour laquelle
l'histoire est un engagement et c'est
vraiment cette interview moi m'a
totalement retourné et c'est cette
invité m'a totalement retourné dans dans
ma façon de penser à chos la recommande
d'ailleurs.
ligne
et elle est en ligne cette idée que
finalement ce sont des brèches et que on
ne progresse on ne progresse et on ne
fait progresser la société que
précisément en créant des brèches. L'une
des principales remarques et l'une des
principales critiques qu'on a eu quand
on a fait une des projections débat avec
démocratie, c'était Ouais mais c'est
sympa mais c'est à l'échelle d'une usine
en Grèce, de la ville de Barcelone, de
l'Islande, d'une école en Belgique, tout
ça c'est sympa votre truc mais comment
on fait à l'échelle de la France ? Mais
qui a dit qu'on avait besoin de faire à
l'échelle de la France ? Je regarde ce
que je disais tout à l'heure. Moi, j'y
crois pas au progrès l'échelle de la
France. Pourquoi est-ce que tu as des
femmes qui se réunissent dans des
réunions non mixtes ? Pourquoi est-ce
que tu as des personnes racisées qui se
réunissent dans des réunions non mixtes
? parce qu'elles ont besoin de ces
espaces-là pour penser autre chose, pour
penser à un monde dans lequel ça
n'existerait pas. Pourquoi elles peuvent
pas faire des réunions mixes ? Parce que
sinon elles vont se faire expliquer la
vie par des mecs, vont se faire
expliquer la vie par des blancs. Voilà
la raison. C'est juste ça. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui tu as des
communautés et tu connais le sujet mieux
que moi, pourquoi tu as des communautés
numériques qui créent des espaces de
réflexion dans lesquels elles
expérimentent des modes de décision
décentralisés ? La la démocratie
liquide, ça est d'abord né du principe
d'attribution de droits de vote par des
systèmes de confiance et de paix à
paire. au travers des réseaux qui ont
une ont une inspiration, une essence qui
n'est possible que grâce à cette
fluidité numérique là. Pourquoi on
l'applique pas dans le réel ? Bah parce
que pour l'instant en fait la résistance
est trop forte mais si on l'expériente
pas à plus petite échelle, on pourra
jamais l'appliquer dans le réel.
Alors je te coupe, je te coupe et euh je
vais encore me faire tper sur les doigts
parce que je te coupe.
Je t'en prie. Pas par moi.
Et euh
pourquoi cette résistance en face ? une
résistance parce queils ont peur de
perdre leur pouvoir. C'est une on va
prendre le cas de l'État.
Pourquoi pourquoi il y a pas de solution
politique à la crise des gilets jaunes
et ainsi de suite ? C'est c'est quoi ?
C'est une résistance parce que ils
veulent pas lâcher le pouvoir ou c'est
une résistance parce que ils savent
pertinemment qu'il n'y aura pas de
solution qui va convaincre tout le monde
? Moi moi je pense que le point de
départ c'est de la problématique c'est
c'est une espèce de
de H clos mental de ces catégories de
population ce qu'on fait ce qu'on sont
grandi dans ce qui ont grandi dans les
dans les beaux quartiers qui on fait des
bons lycées puis de bonnes petites
écoles qui ont été protégées qui ont
grandi sans jamais je je je je je
compartimente un peu un peu
schématiquement dans problème
sociologique mais quand même c'est ces
gens-là sont issus du même catégorie et
je pense qu'ils ont l'intime conviction
avant même du Je se poser la question
que effectivement il y a eux l'élite
ceux qui savent ceux qui sont touchés
par la grâce et puis il y a le bas
peuple, il y a les gens les gilets
jaunes quoi, les ouvriers, les paysans,
les employés, les chômeurs, les les
caissières qui sont ils sont mais ces
gens-là ils sont pas ils sont pas le
peuple quoi. Ce peuple bah ils sont pas
en situation de pouvoir décider de de
pouvoir décider de leur propre destin.
D'ailleurs, on va le faire pour eux
nous. Il y a il y a ce présupposé là euh
ouais, j'ai touché mon micro, je suis
désolé. Euh il y a ce présupposé là et
qui est et qui est qui est pas
interrogé. S'il n'est pas interrogé
après mécaniquement quand ces gens sont
au pouvoir parce qu'il les accède plus
facilement évidemment quand tu grandis
dans le 16e et que tu as l'ançon de
sailli puis après tu enchaînes par
science pouosses un peu tu peux y
arriver et cetera ou si au contraire tu
fais tu passes par par d'autres billets
pour y parvenir. Euh et ben une fois que
tu es tu es en situation de pouvoir bah
déjà tu penses même pas à partager.
C'est c'est même pas délibéré. C'est pas
je regarder pour moi parce que ils
pourraient non il considèrent même pas
finalement le peuple comme un opposant
sérieux. Il y a ce mépris de classe
initiale. Ça c'est c'est ça me semble
être le terro. Ensuite il y a des
stratégies le pouvoir, je veux le
conserver. Il y a des forces adverses
dans le champ politique qui est le mien
de la démocratie représentative des
élections où je vais quand même me
mettre un peu en danger. J'ai conquis le
pouvoir, il faut pas que je le perde.
Donc je vais jouer sur tous les tous les
ressorts possibles. Tous les tous les
tous les registres sont bons. Euh et
voilà. On va pas interroger si si on
fait un grand débat, on va faire un show
permanent avec un un one man du
président au milieu face à des élus ou
un public trié qui qui applaudit à la
toute fin et B ça cos au deè tour.
Vas-y vas-y.
Vous dans la présidentielle ?
J'ai pas voté.
[__] j'ai honte mais je vais être
honnête, j'ai voté contre Marine Le Pen.
J'ai honte. J'ai honte. Non mais
vraiment vraiment en fait j'ai réagi.
Moi je suis un mec du je suis pas tout
jeune, je suis le plus le plus âgé du du
collectif
castor c'est ça ?
Ouais presque. Ouais je suis un enfant
du 20e siècle et effectivement en
réflexe j'ai j'ai je je ouais en réflexe
je vote contre contre Le Pen. Je me
mords les doigts dans la demi-conde qui
suit. C'est dire je suis pas dup une
demi-conde mais je le fais
mécaniquement. Je je c'est c'est je me
le reproche. Alors au ça c'est pas quand
ça s'est reproduit au litiislative je
l'ai pas fait voilà mais à ce moment-là
je je je pouvais pas. C'était presque à
mon corps défendant. Pardon. C'est une
sorte de d'au.
Je voulais revenir sur ce que tu disais.
Je je suis d'accord avec beaucoup de ce
qu'a dit Henry, mais j'ajouterai un truc
important, c'est c'est quoi l'état ? Tu
vois, bourdieu sur l'état, tu tu lis son
cours et en fait au bout de trois qu
chapitres après être passé par les
maisons Phonix, des études de terrain,
c'est passionnant, il arrive et il dit
"Bah finalement l'État, c'est juste à un
moment une institution qui a le cran, la
folie de monter sur l'estrades et de
dire je suis l'État." C'est ça qui
s'autoproclame en fait. Et en gros, je
résumerai ça par une formule. Choisis ta
fiction, camarade. H
euh le la domination masculine est une
fiction. Il y a pas c'est injustifiable.
Les écarts de salaire, les écarts de
traitement, les violences sur les femmes
sont injustifiables d'une manière
rationnelle. Les écarts de traitement
entre les personnes blanches et non
blanches sont injustifiables de manière
rationnelle. Comment tu justifies ? Et
ben, tu le construis. La manif pour
tous, un papa, une maman et mon cul sur
la commode. Combien il y a d'enfants
illégitimes nés ? dans des cadres
familieux où on a étouffé l'affaire. On
ét fait dans un jardin d'hiver, c'est ça
?
De quoi ?
Qu' on été fait dans un jardin d'hiver
par exemple ou alors ou alors on a dû
renvoyer la bonne. Non mais sans
déconner quoi, la la famille est une
fiction. Ça peut être une fiction
inclusive ouverte où on dit alors en
fait c'est juste les gens qui s'occupent
des enfants qui sont les parents et le
reste on s'en bat les steaks. On peut se
dire ça. Ça c'est une belle fiction
inclusive. Et puis tu as les gens qui
vont dire "Ah non, si jamais on fait ça
après la société va s'effondrer." Alors
en fait en juste un exemple, la PMA pour
toutes, c'est tellement sacrilège, ça
fout tellement le bordel et on est
tellement des latins qui pouvont pas
accepter ça que c'est légal en Espagne
depuis 77.
Donc si tu veux les chacun chacun sa
fiction, choisis ta fiction. C'est ça
aussi le le le principe et la pensée
utopique, c'est qu'il y a un moment où
le roi est nu, tu regardes et tu dis "Ah
bah merde en fait" et tu dis "Bah est-ce
que je est-ce que je suis confort dans
ma caverne ou est-ce que je décide de
sortir ? Être libre, c'est ça en fait.
Être libre, c'est savoir que comme tout
est construction, tu peux devoir
construire comme tu le souhaites. Et ça,
ça te libère, ça t'émancipe.
Qui peut me décrire ce qu'est un famille
?
Ah bah, tu vois, j'ai de guise de
Ah bah après, il y a pas un famistère,
c'est une théorie au départ en fait.
C'est ces Fourriers, pardon,
vas-y, vas-y. C'est Fourrier euh donc
qui euh essayant de matérialiser des
idées socialistes mais très ancrées dans
la révolution industrielle qui euh
qui Oui, j'allais le dire qui allait qui
euh qui euh se développait en France et
au Royaume-Uni au 19e siècle de la même
manière que Owen de l'autre côté de de
la Manche. Se dit que finalement il y a
un un équilibre à réétablir et un lieu à
créer qui pourrait réunir plusieurs
fonctions sociales. celle du travail,
celle de la communauté, des fonctions
politiques, le soin aux enfants, le
commerce, que tout ça pourrait être dans
un lieu unique. Et il se trouve que un
jour à Guise, donc dans l'ine, n'est-ce
pas, on est construit le famille
ministère de Guise qui tente de
cristalliser ce principe autour d'une
usine autour de laquelle tout est
organisé. C'est finalement une société,
une microciété qui se reforme autour du
travail. Et il se trouve que on a appris
notamment en discutant avec Michel
Lallemand à l'occasion d'un des
entretiens dans le cadre de la
préparation de feuilles d'OC que le FA
ministère avait semé mais au-delà de la
France aux États-Unis notamment qui eu
des tentatives de fem ministère à
l'étranger et cette idée et que Owen c
du de l'autre côté de la Manche a fait
son propre village industriel, ses
propres théories en Écosse avec cette
idée toujours que bah on peut refonder
une société et on peut refonder un
collectif autour d'une notion. Là, c'est
le travail par exemple et ailleurs,
c'est aussi le travail. Et l'idée du
fait milistère a essé dans plein
d'autres mouvements, y compris des
mouvements euh dans les années 60 et 70
aux États-Unis qui sont inspirés de ce
rapport au travail pour créer des
communautés dans laquelle le travail
sera la seule monnaie d'échange et
l'argent aboli. Donc, c'est une c'est
une utopie. C'est l'une des utopies
fondatrices du mouvement utopique du 19e
siècle et qui aujourd'hui encore
continue d'inspirer plein de gens qui
souhaitent mettre le travail au centre.
Mais on peut mettre le beaucoup d'autres
choses au centre des utopies et euh ça
va aussi être un peu le l'objet de nos
recherches.
Ah,
c'était pas préparé. On est d'accord.
On est d'accord. Euh donc ça me permet
de rebondir sur votre projet.
Super.
En ce moment, vous êtes en train de
faire un crowfunding pour financer
combien d'épisodes ? Pour parler de quoi
? Combien vous avez besoin, pourquoi
vous faites un crowfunding, comment vous
allez travailler, qui va toucher, quoi,
est-ce que vous payez vos impôts ?
Vous allez payer vos impôts en France,
vous faites de l'évasion fiscale, oui,
non. Allez, hop, c'est à vous. On fait
pas des raisons fées. Je par la fin. Euh
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on va essayer de faire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on souhaite faire ? Une
série documentaire de deux, trois
peut-être quatre épisodes
d'une heure chacun qui va faire le tour
qui va tenter de faire une sorte de tour
pas exhaustif bien évidemment mais de de
d'utopie concrète qui se déroule
aujourd'hui ici et maintenant. Quand je
dis ici, ça peut être en Amérique du Sud
à
au cœurs distan par exemple pour ne euh
mais également aux États-Unis, en
France, euh en Europe, en Afrique aussi
euh de différentes natures et pas
simplement d'ailleurs des utopies ou des
constructions de mondes idéaux dans la
réalité qui correspondent à nos
présupposés théoriques. On s'intéresse
par exemple au Systeding. Je sais pas si
vous le Steedading, ça a été cofinancé
très tôt par Peter Til le l'un des
créateurs de PayPal milliardaire s'il en
est. Pardon ?
Non non parce que ça fait écho à la
dernière fois.
Euh et qui en fait le principe de
Systing, c'est des des îles flottantes
dans les eaux extraterritoriales pour
pour ne pas se soumettre au au aux lois
de chacun des pays qui les entourent et
qui sont réservés évidemment à quelques
millionnaires qui peuvent parce que le
ticket d'entrée c'est 15 millions de
dollars mais il présentent ça quand même
effectivement un monde idéal susceptible
de répondre aux différentes crises
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
notamment crise sanitaire et puis
écologique et de régement climatique.
L'idée c'est par épisode de confronter
plusieurs théories, de les de voir
comment plusieurs utopies, deux utopies
à chaque fois pour voir dans les
frictions ce que ça raconte de
l'Amazonnie assisted de du du des
libertariens du Freestate Project à la
Rojava. Euh voilà, donc on veut aller
tourner sur le terrain de m'a très
immersive, c'est passer 15 jours, 3
semaines, un mois ou plusieurs fois, une
semaine euh au Curdistan, aux
États-Unis, en Amazonnie pour voir
comment ces gens euh vivent.
C'est-à-dire qu'il s'agira pas
simplement de plaquer des images qui
illustrent un propos qui sera écrit, il
y aura pas de voix off. On va juste euh
tenter de rendre compte de cette réalité
danger parce que c'est pas que des idées
hein la vie. Euh c'est également euh
comment tu passes de l'idée à la
réalité, c'est ça engage le corps le
matin, le petit-déjeuner, le dîner, la
discussion avec les autres, avec ceux
qui qui collaborent à ton à ta
proposition, à ta construction. Donc
c'est un récit documentaire assez pur en
fait et une véritable enquête.
Aujourd'hui, on en est au stade de la
réflexion, on étudie différents types de
projets. Moi, j'ai par exemple une envie
très très forte sur la roja. Je crois
que cette discussion l'a prouvé. Je
pense que c'est un quasiment un
impératif, c'est un épicentre. Alors
évidemment, qu'est-ce que ça va payer ?
Si on part dans la RJAVA filmée avec une
équipe technique pour partie issue de
mes équipes classiques, de nos équipes
classique mais également avec les gens
du coin parce que je pense qu'on va
essayer aussi de limiter au maximum
l'empreinte écologique de nos
déplacements autant que possible et
aussi de compenser financièrement quand
ça quand on pourra pas limiter ce qu'on
ne pourra pas limiter mais on va
travailler avec des des des populations
locales évidemment des des
collaborateurs locaux des ingestions
locaux peut-être des cadreurs locaux des
régisseurs locaux évidemment euh
qu'est-ce que ça paye
c'est cher un documentaire comme ça
c'est du temps, ce sont des
intermittents de spectacle, c'est des
des des ressources locales impliquées
par le projet.
Et par exemple, si on quand on ira parce
que je pense que nous irons au
curdistan, bah c'est toute une
logistique de sécurité parce que c'est
un peu chaud de de préparation. Donc
c'est plusieurs mois de travail,
d'enquête, de préparation et plusieurs
mois de de tournage. Donc on demande
200000 € sur la page Kis Bank Bank
Utopie Data.
pour payer l'intégralité des salaires
des quatre personnes qui travaillent
pour l'instant donc Julien, Sylvain,
Lauren et ma pomme qui ont travaillé en
préparation peut-être une ou deux
ressources également d'enquêteurs qui
sont en lien avec ces différents
territoires et ensuite 6 7 mois 8 mois
de tournage avant de lancer après la
post-production le montage de ces 3 4
peut-être 5 heures de programme. Voilà.
Tout est dit.
Comment on est payé ? On est payé au
tarif syndical. Tous les intermittents,
nous sommes intermittents, les auteurs.
Il y a des tarifs syndicaux, des
conventions collectives. Alors, ni plus
ni moins que ce que impose la convention
collective qu'on respecte à la lettre.
Évidemment,
je peux vous demander un truc personnel,
utiliser mon
mon ma position pour vous demander
quelque chose. Si vous allez faire des
des images un peu un peu dans les
endroits qu'on a pas l'habitude de
visiter, vous auriez l'amabilité de
filmer en 360°
en VR.
Ah oui, bien sûr, pourquoi pas ? Non,
bien sûr. Et ce qui serait génial, c'est
de faire du live comme ça, c'est d'avoir
des instants live. Alors, je reviens sur
la le crowfunding. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait un financement participatif ? C'est
pas juste pour demander du pognon.
Euh, on est soutenu également, enfin
c'est en discussion mais c'est il y a un
développement qui est signé avec France
Télévision par France TV/ la cha le le
le numérique de France Télévision. Le
numérique de France Télévision c'est
encore un peu le parent pauvre de du
groupe France Télévision. C'est pas une
grosse chaîne linéaire. Donc ils ont des
moyens qui sont limités qui
s'accompagnent
d'agueul depuis l'origine mais ça suffit
pas complètement. Donc il y a aussi des
apports personnels de production, le
CNC, mais au-delà de la nécessité
financière hein d'être d'être soutenu
parce qu'on pourrait pas le faire sans
le crowfunding de de de faire appel au
financement participatif, c'est aussi
une manière d'entretenir une relation
très singulière et très forte et
renforcée avec la communauté, avec ceux
auquels on adresse le film et qui l'ont
rendu possible. On l'a vécu avec
démocratie. Le fait d'avoir 7819 crow
funder, je reçois a toujours ce nom.
Démocratie. Ouais. démocratie où on
interroit le principe de démocratie, on
interrogit la démocratie participative
et très rapidement all voir ce qui ce
qu'on appelle la démocratie réelle dans
toute sa complexité, le fait de
d'écouter l'autre, d'intégrer dans le
processus de décision des des conflits,
des antagonismes,
considérer que chacun a autant le droit
que moi de décider. Euh et voilà, je
vous invite à regarder ce film qui est
en ligne sur la chaîne de ta gueule.
Donc film qui s'est prolongé euh de
manière très forte parce que ce que l'on
fait, on le met en Creative Commons.
Donc chacun a pu s'en emparer par la
suite, un peu comme toi d'ailleurs,
hein. Je sais que SVW est un CR Commons.
Bravo pour ça. C'est essentiel, c'est un
combat essentiel. C'est une forme
d'utopie de de distribution aussi. Euh
et ça CR com ça a permis de de des
centaines de projections à travers la
France, en Belgique, en Suisse, au
Québec, dans les pays majoritairement
francophones, mais également dans
d'autres pays non francophones.
projection auxquelles on a pu se rendre
euh bien sûr projection gratuite, nous
on ti rend gratos évidemment euh et
c'est un c'est un objet partagé, c'est
un objet collectif du coup ça nous
appartient plus. Alors, on est des
artisans, on fait notre film parce qu'on
commence sait le faire même dans
l'instant où on le fait, le fait de
partager par exemple effectivement un
instant quelques minutes au plein cœur
de Cobané euh d'une image 360 de la
réédité tangible des rues Cobané
aujourd'hui et le partager
instantanément dans notre journal de
bord avec les contributeurs. Oui, c'est
bien, c'est fort, ça crée un lien fort.
L'ubiquité.
Alors, on va passer au Tu veux rajouter
quelque chose ?
Non. On va passer à quelques questions
d'internet que je vais prendre à la
volée.
Alors, pourquoi avoir fait cette vidéo
sur la psychiatrie des remords
pointinterrogation ? Une question de
Julien.
Julien G qui pose une question. Ah, j'ai
reconnu Julien Guz. Moi je vais j'avais
préparé une réponse, tu vas préciser
après. Je pense que tu vas être en fait
euh c'est c'est vachement révélateur
d'une problématique de ce que le web
aujourd'hui il y a un mec qui nous a
fake news. Il y a les fake news et il y
a les good news.
En fait ce que nous ont reproché
certains une partie de de de de enfin
certains psychiatres un notamment et
quelquesuns à sa suite mais un surtout
alors que d'autres nous défendaient des
psychiatres cliniciens notamment celui
qu'on a invité c'est vraiment un d'où je
me place d'où je regarde.
La la on a abordé le problème de la
psychiatrie sous l'angle de la
médicalisation communique recours sous
la le solutionnisme du médicament. Tu as
un problème
ça la psychiatrie soviétique,
c'est ça. Tu as un problème, je te file
un cacheton, tu as plus de problème, je
schématise, je simplifie. Euh et on a
dit voilà euh dans l'histoire de la
psychiatrie, il y a une évolution. Euh
les premières recommandations
collectives, la DRM, c'est ça hein, euh
des années 60 proposit la
psychothérapie, le langage. Et puis
après, il y a une bascule dans les
années 80 90. Et puis cette bascule là,
elle est pas pour rien. Il y a les
enjeux économiques
et et aussi ça participe à une sorte de
solutionnisme qui est vachement dans
l'air du temps de notre libéralisme.
C'est une question politique dire
on a un problème politique, il faut un
homme providentiel, tu as un problème de
santé mentale, tu prends un médicament,
tout ça c'est fastoche. Euh solution
simple. Alors que c'est un problème
d'une complexité infinie qu'on a bien
sûr pas euh tenté de résoudre avec ce
cette cette cet épisode, on a juste posé
des questions et c'est des questions qui
sont des questions tabou. Il y a ceux
qui savent et ceux qui savent pas. Il se
trouve qu'il y a heureusement plein de
psychiatres notamment cliniciens qui euh
alors on nous a reproché de dire fall
pas prendre de médicaments. Non dans le
motion design on dit qu'il faut prendre
des médicaments des médicaments qui sont
effectivement utiles. Évidemment on
n'est pas médecin mais bien sûr s'ils
ont pris ce qu'il sait qu'ils le sont.
Euh et de surcroix, le psychiatre auquel
on donne la parole dans le deuxème temps
de de de l'épisode dit "J'utilise les
médicaments mais pas seulement, mais
également la parole, mais également le
temps." Évidemment,
la discussion, cirque
le cirque qu'est-ce par le cirque ?
C'est c'est une méthode canadienne avec
le cirque.
D'accord. Bon, pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas des psych psychothérapie de groupe,
il y a 1000 manières en tout cas il y a
plein de manières qui nécessitent du
temps. Et cette question est une
question politique, c'est pas qu'une
question médicale, c'est une question
politique. Et donc il y a pas les
tenants de ceux qui ont raison et ceux
qu'on tort. Euh voilà, c'est ça me
paraît euh
Je vais juste ajouter un truc important,
mais sans sans rien retirer à ce qu'a
dit Henry,
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une il y a
une il y a un désir et une demande de
posture que nous on souhaite pas avoir à
savoir celle du donneur de leçon. du du
de celui qui inflige la vérité. Et
souvent quand je lis les commentaires,
je pense beaucoup aux confrères et
consœurs notamment euh de la super
émission de la cellule investigation de
Radio France et où chaque fois queils
reçoivent le médiateur ou la médiatrice
de Radio France, en gros le truc c'est
dans tel épisode vous avez dit du mal
des psychiatres, est-ce que vous vous
repentez ? Alors en fait les enquêtes
c'est jamais la psychiatrie, pourquoi
c'est pas bien ? c'est de dire il y a eu
des dérives dans la psychiatrie, il y a
eu des dérives dans tel type de leasing
de baraque, il y a eu des dérives dans
tel truc. Jamais il condamne
unilatéralement toute une catégorie,
toute une pratique, tout un machin. Mais
les personnes qui sont dedans le
prennent en tant que tel. Et du coup le
pr le pauvre Jacques Monin se trouve
régulièrement à devoir dire "Alors,
écoutez, réécouter l'émission" ou alors
les gens qui disent "Oui, vous en êtes
pris à à Jean-Luc Mélenchon, pourquoi
vous critiquez pas Macron deux émissions
plutôt et critiquer Macron et on se
retrouve un peu dans la même posture où
finalement à aucun moment nous ne disons
il ne faut pas prendre de médicament, on
pointe une dérive des méthodes de
prescription en psychiatrie. Il y a
peut-être des alors il y a peut-être des
études qu'on a soulevé qui étaient en
débat et qui font débat ou qui ont même
été réuis entre-temps et auquel cas bah
c'est des erreurs et ça pour le coup
c'est c'est dommageable et je le
regrette mais à aucun moment et le
script est en ligne la vidéo est en
ligne nous disons il ne faut pas prendre
de médicament les médicaments ne servent
à rien. Notre invité comme le rappel
Henry dit je prescris des médicaments
quand c'est approprié et c'était juste
notre message. Et dans face de ça, tu as
des personnes qui ne veulent pas qu'on
conteste l'idée même. L'idée même
c'est une chasse gardée quoi.
Et du coup bah on radicalise un propos
qui n'est absolument pas aussi
caricatural que celui qui tel qu'il le
critique.
Alors autre question comment penser une
utopie inclusive point d'interrogation
donc sans terroriser point
d'interrogation et j'en lis une deuxième
qui allait sensiblement être connectée à
celle-ci.
Ça de ouvre les guillemets sa fiction
inclusive ça ressemble à la fin de
l'histoire. Est-ce que vous vous refusez
à penser des problèmes qui pourrait
émerger avec de telles fictions ? Pour
interrogation, il y a des groupes
inclusifs qui se foutent sur la gueule
en interne pour
bien sûr. Pardon. Bon, vas-y.
Non, mais je veux dire le principe du
documentaire en fait, on veut on est là
comme des comme si enfin c'est aussi
notre notre point de départ mais dont on
va se libérer très rapidement après
cette campagne de financement parce
qu'on est en campagne aussi, c'est assez
régressif d'être en campagne. C'est
qu'on on restreint sur les possibles, on
a des espèces de punchline qu'on prépare
ou des ou une manière de nous adresser à
ceux qui nous écoutent qui simplifient
la pensée. On n'est pas pour telle ou
telle solution. On dit ce qui est
intéressant et c'est une démarche
documentaire, c'est d'aller voir et
d'aller voir la complexité, d'aller voir
les difficultés, d'aller voir les
impasses. Il s'agit pas de faire un film
militant pour les utopies. Ça n'aurait
pas de sens. Il s'agit de voir comment
fonctionne, comment vivent celles et
ceux qui tentent autre chose autrement.
Et pas simplement des gens avec lesquels
on serait appris. Oui. D'accord. C'est
pas le sujet. Ce qui le sujet, c'est
cette extraordinaire énergie, ce courage
fabuleux que je n'ai pas encore de
changer jusqu'à sa vie et de et de avec
soi, avec ses proches et avec des
collectifs plus ou moins grands de
transformer sa réalité, de faire sa
brèche. Et ça c'est un courage
extraordinaire. C'est un courage qui
peut avoir effectivement des
défaillances, qui peut générer des
effets pervers et qu'on qu'on tentera de
documenter qu'on va pas masquer. On fait
pas un film pour ou contre les utopies.
Rappelle-moi la page du crowfunding,
c'est quoi ? KKBB sur Kiskiss BankBank
euh/ash Après, on cherche sur Utopie sur
Kiskiss BankBank et on trouve tout de
suite.
Alors
juste par comme comme ça faisait
référence à un truc que j'avais dit sur
les fictions inclusives euh oui
effectivement dans dans cette fiction
inclusive, il y a des gens qui se
foutent sur la gueule parce que dans les
fictions non inclusives, personne se
fout sur la gueule. Enfin pour le coup,
juste pour la blague hein, j'ai moi j'ai
commencé ma modeste carrière en 2006
pour en suivant le Front National.
Ouais.
Ouais. chez Marianne. Euh je suivais le
Front National pendant la campagne, la
dernière campagne de de Jean-Marie Le
Pen. Euh et en l'occurrence enfin aller
voir dans les mouvements d'extrême
droite, aller voir dans les mouvements
racistes, aller voir dans les mouvements
euh virilistes euh machin, euh ils se
foutent sur la gueule. C'est quoi ?
Enfin, en moi, pour moi, c'est pas un
argument. le conflit n'est pas un
problème en soi. Par contre, le fait
d'exclure les gens sur certains
critères, bah du coup, tu piétines un
petit peu un principe qui est l'égalité
et qui a en théorie fait partie de nos
valeurs fondamentales. Donc c'est quand
je parlais de fiction inclusive, je
disais tu peux envisager la famille de
divers de diverses manières. Il y a des
gens qui aujourd'hui disent un papa une
maman, ça c'est une fiction exclusive
parce qu'il y a toute une catégorie de
la population qui ne se reconnaîtra et
ne pourra jamais intégrer ce système.
Est-ce que tu peux envisager une autre
fiction qui elle serait inclusive ?
C'était ça le sens de ma remarque.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des gens qui
disent voilà
il faut pas aller voir les gars du Front
National, il faut pas aller discuter
avec eux, il faut pas les écouter, il
faut pas leur donner la parole ?
C'est une bonne question et mon avis a
beaucoup évolué là-dessus. J'ai suivi le
FN pendant plusieurs années chez
Marianne.
C'était une expérience hyper
enrichissante parce que tu vois
concrètement l'organisation sociale que
qui a derrière, tu as des gens qui ont
été repêchés littéralement dans le
ruisseau, tu vois, dans des situations
sociales pas possibles et qui ont connu
une une
carrière et ont pu avoir une influence
et ont pu avoir un destin grâce à grâce
à la famille Le Pen. Je le ni pas.
Après, la question pour moi aujourd'hui
et je me la repose avec mes co-auteurs
et co-autrices, c'est euh est-ce qu'on a
le temps ? En fait, quand on a fait, tu
disais tout à l'heure notre premier
documentaire, en fait démocratie c'était
le deuxè, on en avait fait un sur le
changement climatique s'appelait 2
degrés avant la fin du monde.
On va d'ailleurs poster aujourd'hui sur
Twitter
et merci encore pour ça, c'est cool. Et
en fait, on s'est posé la question à un
moment de est-ce qu'on donne la parole
le climatoceptique ?
Et là se pose une question très basique
qui est une question d'économie
de l'expression. public, c'est-à-dire
combien de temps tu as, combien de temps
on a nous là ensemble pour avoir notre
discussion. Le temps, il est limité. Il
y a certaines choses que je vais pas
dire parce que je pense que je veux
économiser ce temps-là pour parler de
choses plus importantes. Les
climatosceptiques, on leur donne déjà
énormément beaucoup trop la parole. Les
si tu veux entendre des propos qui
stigmatisent les personnes racisées, les
musulmans, les femmes,
j'ai pas compris. C'est une question de
budget ou c'est une question
d'économie en terme de temps ? Ici la
ressource c'est le temps. C'est quand tu
n'as que 90 minutes dans un documentaire
consacrer 5 minutes au climatosceptiqu
sur changement climatique. Consacrer 5
minutes au climatosceptique ça veut dire
5 minutes de moins pour faire parler
quelqu'un qui va dire autre chose que ce
qu'on
pas de problème de temps ni d'argent.
Moi je pense que s' s'agit pas de faire
parler pour faire parler d'offrir une
tribune offrir une tribune ça a pas de
sens. En revanche démonter démontrer,
donner à voir effectivement c'est
vachement intéressant. J'ai j'ai perdu
le titre du film du documentaire film
documentaire récent qui s'intéresse à un
militant du Front National pendant la
dernière campagne de Marine Le Pen dans
l'ordre de la France. Le regard, c'est
un film absolument brillant qu'il faut
absolument regarder. J'espère que vous
mettrez en lien le titre, ça va me
revenir, mais là l'instant ça m'échappe.
qui suivent ce ce ce
méditan et tu comprends la la la
distance du point de vue des
documentaristes est une distance d'une
grande subtilité et c'est peut-être le
film le plus pertinent pour décoder tout
ce qu'il y a de pervers, d'absurde dans
les propositions politiques des de de la
famille Le Pen incarnée pendant cette
campagne par la fille avant que ce soit
peut-être un jour la niè ce que ce qu'il
y a de superchie que cette espèce de de
de vol incroyable, de mensonges farineux
de cette cette posture pseudo populaire
alors que ce sont des grandes nantilles
qui mépris cette répartition extrêmement
verticale là encore tu vois ce ce ce
type qui est qui est sincère. Bon bah il
se trouve qu'il a des des des valeurs
qu'il qu'il ramène de patriotisme. Tu
comprends ? C'est son son mouvement
initial. Bon tu es pas là pour le juger
ou c'est pas bien.
Je sais pas j'ai pas à juger. C'est
c'est le fruit d'un parcours. C'est une
construction personnelle. Si tu grandis
dans une famille où effectivement c'est
une valeur importante, bah pourquoi pas
? C'est pas balance, c'est ce que tu en
faire. Après, comment tu le transformes
? si tu le transformes en en exclusion,
en violence contre l'autre, contre la
différence, si tu es manipulé par des
gens qui effectivement utilise cette
énergie là, ce passé là pour pour mettre
mettre à l'écart des catégories de la
population, des migrants des des
immigrés de 2e 3è génération, des
Français qui qui ne te ressemblent pas,
c'est problématique. Et si c'est le goût
du du du 15 de France quand quand on bat
les Anglais au Stade de France, bah
c'est c'est pas inintéressant aussi.
J'en sais rien, j'ai pas à juger. C'est
ici c'est le son de cloche dans les
campagnes et pas le son du minaret dans
les campagnes. Ça se comprend, ça se
comprend pas. Je me fais encore la
vocalité.
Ouais. J'entends bien parce que en fait
opposé comme ça le min le minaré le
minaré au clocher. Donc l'église
le catholicisme
à à la
à l'islam, ça laissera entendre
qu'effectivement il y a un désir
d'hégémonie de l'islam et qui ferait que
nous résistions. C'est un récit ça. Un
récit. Rien me prouve que c'est le cas.
Enfin dire concrètement je dis pas qu'il
y a pas quelques groupes d'islamistes
qui n'est pas ce fantasme là. Ils l'ont,
mais je ne vois pas de de de rafale, de
tsunami euh euh islamiste en France euh
euh qui met en danger effectivement la
c'est c'est c'est une histoire poserait
problème qu'on entende euh par exemple,
imagine-toi dans le trou du cul du monde
de la Bretagne alors que la Bretagne
n'est pas le trou du cul du monde, euh
au lieu d'entendre le son de cloche à 4h
pour sonner ton goûter, euh est-ce que à
6h du matin on appelle la prière, ça te
poserait problème ?
Moi dans l'absolu, je m'en fous
complètement. Je m'en fous complètement.
Bah écoute, ayant eu le plaisir de
rencontrer des gens comme je disais au
Burkina, au Sénégal et cetera, la
en France, en Bretagne ?
Ah en bah écoute,
j'ai j'ai pas en fait ça paraît
tellement bizarre présenter comme ça. Je
saurais je saurais pas te répondre. Je
vais te le représenter. Je vais te le
représenter plus simplement.
Non non parce que non non non
attention attention je vais m'énerver.
OK pas éner
Comment ça s'est présenté ? Je sais pas.
J'ai en fait j'ai du mal j'ai du mal à
voir où où est très simple. Je veux pas
en venir de quoi que ce soit. Je fais je
me fais je me fais la voquer du diable.
Un minérat en Bretagne.
J'entends des gens sur internet qui
braillent à longueur de journée comme
quoi il va y avoir un appel à la prière
bientôt en France. Ce qu'il y a des
prières de rue ainsi de suite.
Ouais, il y a des prières de rue mais
pour des raisons qui sont des raisons en
fait de
parce qu'ils ont pas de mosqué parce que
suite on est d'accord. Mais là si je te
pose la question est-ce que ça te pose
problème d'entendre un appel à la prière
en France en plein milieu de la campagne
?
Non.
Quel est le Non.
Je vais revenir sur ma réponse qu'en
fait c'est pas je m'en fous
complètement. Moi ce qui m'embête c'est
que tout d'un coup l'expression de la
foi de quelques-uns prennent le pas
prennent le pas sur un collectif dont je
suis dans ce parti. Il y a pas de raison
pour moi effectivement le le le clocher
de l'église je l'ai intégré pour moi
comme un truc qui me donne l'heure. Je
suis pas baptisé. Si je pas baptisé, je
sais pas, on est pour j'observe
j'observe le rituel de l'église. Je
rentrer cinq fois dans une église
pendant un office et je trouve ça
étonnant. Je trouve cette théâtratalité
assez surprenante mais je l'observe de
la même manière que quand je vais filmer
des chaman en Sibérie. Tu vois, je
trouve ça vachement intéressant à
observer ou des bouddhistes. Euh mais ça
me parle pas autrement. Évidemment, si
l'appel à la prière et l'expression
d'une hégémonie, c'est ça me pose
problème à ce moment-là. C'est un peu
problème parce que c'est une expression
et finalement m'emmerdez pas. J'ai moi
j'ai pas envie d'aller prier donc pas à
la prière, je viendrai pas. Voilà donc
ça m'emmerde. Mais mais sinon pour le
reste euh je pense que c'est là encore
c'est un fantasme. C'estàd que tu c'est
c'est une manière d'agiter un drapeau
rouge ou de de de construire des
angoisses collectives pour pour pas
susciter là encore de la tension, de la
haine, de la radicalité que face à un
problème qui est monté de toute pièce.
Et ça et ça ça profite toujours à ceux
qui construisent ces problèmes. Et ça
profite où dans autant que possible
selon eux dans les dans les dans les
l'ordre des élections dans les urnes.
Voilà.
Alors la deuxième question qui était à
la suite de sa fiction inclusive, ça
ressemble à la fin de l'histoire. Il y
avait que pensent-il de Ar sur image de
Schneiderman, Daniel de son prénom
d'ailleurs et de Tadii qui tombe dans un
média comme RT. N'aurait-il pas pu lui
aussi lancer une chaîne ou un média
comme eux ou Schneiderman ? Est-ce que
c'est vraiment à nous qu'il faut poser
la question ?
On aime bien Schneiderman, on aime bien
Ah oui, Schneiderman ouais, il fait leur
super boulot sur sur
TDI
sont actu.
Moi, j'aime bien ce que fait TI depuis
longtemps. Il pouvait plus le faire sur
P télévision, il allait le faire chez
RT. Je vais pas juger. Il fait bien son
boulot, je crois, j'ai l'impression en
tout cas.
Est-ce que vous voulez parler des
cryptoonnaies ? Non. Les cryptomonnaies,
ça vous intéresse ?
Ouais, bien sûr, ça vous intéresse. On
en parlera peut-être he ou les monnaies
libres tout ça, on peut pas en parler.
Tu veux, je voulais juste dire un petit
excuse-moi, excuse-moi. Je sais que le
temps est compté, c'est pour ça que je
en fait pour que tu me le prends.
Euh non, les cryptomères, ce que je
trouve intéressant, c'est que euh c'est
pas une solution qui moi m'interpelle
dans mes vidéos, mais typiquement pour
moi, c'est l'exemple de la vision
utopique. Tu vois, on parlait tout à
l'heure de du fait ministère de guise et
bah Fourrier, c'est cette idée que le
travail peut réorganiser totalement la
société et résoudre par effet de
ricochet plein de trucs. Il y a la tune
évidemment derrière, mais les
cryptomonnaies, les arguments alors tu
as plein de courants au sein des
cryptomonnaies he évidemment et on le
voit avec la multiplicité d'ailleurs
maintenant des blockchain qui
sous-traitent. Au bout d'un moment, on
disait oui mais en fait il va juste y
avoir il va juste y avoir les Bitcoin.
Mais non maintenant Ethereum devient une
vraie blockchain alternative sur les
cryptos. Et du coup, c'est ce que je
trouve intéressant, c'est que là, tu es
pour moi dans un exemple très paradoxal
mais très intéressant d'utopie numérique
et où tu as des gens qui disent et ben
les cryptonnaies, ça va régler des
problèmes de démocratie parce que les
élections vont être infalsifiables, ça
va régler des problèmes de vol de terre.
Par exemple, il y a des gens qui veulent
appliquer ça au Kenya
blockchain
le mais les cryptomonnaaies et par par
répercussion à la blockchain euh et ça
va permettre en fait typiquement par des
microtransactions de sécuriser des
propriétés terriennes et dans des pays
comme le Kenya où tu as énormément
d'expropriation illégale de terre et ben
ça a empêché ça et je trouve que en cela
c'est une forme de pensée utopique. Je
trouve ça typiquement, tu vois, on est
dans le cas de j'adhère pas forcément
mais je trouve ça super intéressant et
j'ai envie de discuter avec les gens qui
croient parce que là il y a aussi de la
foi qui joue et la foi en un idéal et
qui a une traduction là hyper pratique.
Ça je trouve ça très intéressant.
On a commencé en retard donc on va on va
gratter un peu. On a une deuxième
interview qui arrive donc je vais pas
vous mettre à la porte mais on va
déborder un petit peu avec vous. Et euh
je suis en train de zoter.
Euh il y en a un qui me pose la
question. On peut parler de corruption ?
Bien sûr, on peut pas de corruption.
C'est pas une utopie mais oui,
on a croisé la corruption. Alors, dans
le cadre de la série documentaire, tu
veux dire ? On en a parlé dans dans le
cadre de de la démocratie, notre
document sur la démocratie. Enfin, on
est arrivé alors je vais vite, c'est
marrant, j'ai sentiment du sentiment
d'urgence. J'aimerais qu'on ait
tellement de choses à dire sur la
question des utopies que je me précipite
un peu. En en abordant la démocratie, on
a on a pu se dire que le le
l'organisation de notre démocratie
représentative était corruptiogène.
C'est et la corruption, c'est pas juste
recevoir un une valise de billets, c'est
appliquer des politiques qui ne sont pas
en faveur de ceux qui t'ont élus. les
gens qui te disent aujourd'hui euh
globalement hein quand tu as x millions
de votants, un deuxème tour d'élection
présidentielle, c'est pas x million de
d'ultra privilégiés. Et pour autant les
politiques qui sont mis en place depuis
de nombreuses années hein. Macron n'est
pas le premier, il y a eu Hollande
et puis puis les précédent jusqu'à il y
a longtemps faisant pas d'histoire de la
de la de la de la tromperie, de la
trahison. Mais les politiques sont mis
en place sont en faveur des
multinationales, des milliardaires,
de de de ce haut du panier. Donc
finalement, c'est une forme de
corruption euh une forme de corruption
indirecte avec probablement aussi des
mécanismes de corruption directe, mais
pas je crois pas moi à la au valise de
billet même si euh même si il y en a
probablement eu euh et des de des
journalistes excellents, on peut
travailler dessus et et les révèle
encore aujourd'hui. Mais notre le
système dans lequel nous vivons est
corruptogène. cette cette verticalité,
le principe des lobbyes, le principe de
cette cette collusion d'entre les lieux
de pouvoir politique économique
génère mécaniquement de la corruption et
c'est l'un des problèmes de notre
société.
C'est je rebondis ce que tu dis parce
que c'est très important à saisir. C'est
effectivement l'image de la valise de
billet, c'est très voilà, c'est très
pittoresque, c'est marrant mais en fait
c'est une réalité qui est très
partielle. Moi je me souviens de gens
qui me disaient "Oui mais la corruption
dans les médias, vous êtes payé par payé
par payé par en fait Serge Dasso, il a
pas besoin de décrocher son téléphone.
L'autocensure fait le job. La corruption
comme le disait Henri, c'est la
définition que nous donnait Eric Halt
qui a été à la tête d'anticorps pendant
de nombreuses années. C'est cette idée
effectivement c'est intellectuelle et
quelque part la comparaison que j'aurais
elle est plus littéraire qu'autre chose.
Pour moi, c'est pas l'entir, pas la
boîte hein, on est d'accord ? Toute
ressemblance c'est le Seigneur des
Anneaux. C'est cette idée que finalement
ce pouvoir dont tu uses te bouffe de
l'intérieur parce que tu prends
conscience de ce qui te permet de faire.
Et à cet égard, la corruption c'est ce
moment où tu ne penses plus qu'à ce que
tu peux faire. Et je me souviens avoir
eu cette discussion une fois avec un
député et qui m'avait dit le pouvoir
c'est savoir que si mon fils prend une
prune, je peux décrocher le téléphone et
dire monsieur le préfet et cetera et
cetera et la prune va sauter. Et je
disais mais ça veut dire que vous le
faites ? Il dit non, je peux le faire.
C'est ça le pouvoir et c'est ça le
problème. Ça c'est la corruption. Pensez
à ça. Au lieu de te dire la le pouvoir
est une responsabilité, tu te dis le
pouvoir est une potentialité. Et c'est
là où tu commences à à flinguer le
système et à démanteler de l'intérieur
l'intention démocratique au cœur de nos
institutions.
Alors, qu'on soit bien clair, moi quand
j'appelle mes potes chez Twitter en
Irlande pour qu'il me chope des IP ou
qu' me chope des infos, c'est de la
corruption ou c'est du pouvoir ?
C'est du réseau, c'est autre chose.
C'est c'est un privilège qui est lié à
tes connaissances. C'est ton réseau à
toi. Mais c'est pas du pouvoir parce que
personne ne t'a ne t'a mis là pour que
tu fasses des choses au nom d'autres
personnes. Donc ce que tu uses de ça
pour tes pour tes tes questions
personnelles, tout le monde le fait.
C'est pas la question. Tu n'es pas
représentant. Si tu uses de ça pour te
défendre d'agression injuste, c'est tout
à fait légitime.
OK, je vais je vais juste lire un
commentaire pour la chaîne parce que ça
ça n pas il faut il faut que je réponde
à un commentaire. Comment se fait-il
qu'on ne peut plus commenter en direct ?
Je suis un fan de Singerw et là c'est la
première fois que l'on ne peut pas
commenter ni sur YouTube ni sur
Facebook. Comment ça on peut pas
commenter sur Facebook ? C'est quoi ce
bean ? Ça fout les boules. Je n'étais
pas habitué cela avec Syerview. Alors de
temps en temps ou même souvent sur
Facebook le chat il est actif là sur
Facebook. Il est actif sur Facebook.
Donc de temps en temps, on désactive le
chat sur Facebook qu'on a quand on a
reçu François Dupidi. On a vous
connaissez François du Puider ? Francis
duell,
on l'a reçu, on avait désactivé le chat
parce que on a eu un tomb de de mecs qui
voulaient l'insulter dans tous les sens
et
je me demande sur quel sujet ça a bien
pu
bah c'était pas sur la couleur de ses
chaussettes.
Ouais, ouais, j'en doute pas.
Et et et sur d'autres sujets, on est
donc comme quand on en a assez de voir
un torrent se déverser des fois. Mais
c'est le cas là, vous avez fait ça ou
pas ?
Non non non. le chat sur YouTube euh
d'après notre réalisateur adoré est
toujours actif sur Facebook et sur
YouTube. Euh on arrive à la fin, je suis
désolé de notre interview. Euh question
qu'on pose à tous les invités. Donnez
trois bouquins à lire à notre communauté
ou trois bouquins qui ont été importants
pour vous.
Ah merde !
Et et c'est pas fini. Un conseil pour
les jeunes géniaux. Vous êtes déjà passé
ici quand même ? Vrain 35 ça été déjà
à l'époque et et un conseil pour les
jeunes génération
c'est à vous.
Vas-y je t'en prie.
Et pendant que vous
pendant que vous réfléchissez la
communauté on reprend une interview dans
une demi-heure environ. Donc restez en
ligne.
Je réfléchis. Trois bouquins.
Trois bouquins. Alors la gouvernance par
les nombres d'Alain Supiot Collège de
France. Euh comment la construction non
passe du chiffre mais de l'idée que le
chiffre est la réponse. Typiquement pour
rebondir ce que disait Henri tout à
l'heure, c'est un sujet qui moi me
préoccupe beaucoup la datalitéracie et
comprendre comment la donnée est
elle-même un un un obtenu. Voilà quelque
chose de
le songe.
C'est ça. Alors tu parles de songe. Du
coup je rebondis là-dessus. Ursula
Kellogin les dépossédés euh de la SF
féministe écolo anarchiste fantastique
qui permet de découvrir un truc qui est
rare et c'était des grandes thèses du
Kogwiin c'est on passe la une grosse
partie de notre temps à rêver dans un
moment qui est libre des contingences du
pouvoir et dans ce moment-là on peut
inventer un monde qu'on rêverait donc il
faut peupler les imaginaires de SF de
fantaisie de de ça et c'est ce qu'elle
fait brillamment la main gauche de la
nuit aussi enfin touts formidable qui a
disparu en après un dernier cri de grage
contre Amazon. Donc c'est quelqu'un
d'éminemment recommandable, une autrice
fantastique. Et un troisème bouquin,
c'est horrible, c'est euh
tu veux pas en donner un ou deux toi
d'un coup par de et de
Ah non, j'en aurai un troisième mais il
faut juste d'une seconde plus. Vas-y
Henry,
prépare ton conseil pour les jeunes
générations et vas-y Henry pour les
bouquins.
Ouais. d'un coup c'est le quatreur de
Los Angeles, le James Elroy. Et si je le
dis là parce que c'est c'est en fait
c'est le c'est le par le biais d'enquête
policière, ça commence par le Dalia noir
et ça se termine dans les années 70-80
et après il enchaîne d'ailleurs par une
trilogie vachement intéressante qui
poursuit jusqu'aux jusqu'aux États-Unis
d'aujourd'hui sur contemporain des
États-Unis. Euh, tu vois le la manière
dont le libéralisme, les États-Unis,
donc le le le porte-avion du
libéralisme, du néolibéralisme, euh est
un est un est un est une société
totalement amorale. La question de la
morale, de l'éthique ne se pose pas.
elle est elle est elle est absente,
juste absente. Euh la question de la
justice, de la réciprocité, de de
l'inclusivité, de euh l'égalité sont des
questions qui ne se posent pas et qui
seraient euh non seulement elle se pose
pas, mais il faut pas qu'elle se pose.
Et c'est pas c'est pas un livre à thème,
c'est vraiment c'est du polar avec le
génie de JMC écrit absolument
brillamment très toufu, très complexe
avec des des mais documentés aussi comme
les écrivains américains savent le faire
s'emparant de des problématiques de la
mafia de la constitution des rapports de
pouvoir entre la police. un peu c'est un
peu c'est un peu ce que ce qui prigure
Simon avec son travail the wire que
comment effectivement la une société aux
États-Unis c'est des forces politiques
des forces policières qui sont assez
distinctes qui sont élu voilà et c'est
ce qui est intéressant bon outre le
plaisir du roman et du récit c'est
vraiment l'antithesse de ce qu'on désire
tous naturellement quand on est juste un
tout petit peu attentif
à au bonheur des siens et des autres et
voilà et c'est vachement intéressant
Voilà, je pense que c'est c'est une
démonstration en creux de tout ce que à
ce à quoi on est confronté en fait.
3è roman d'actualité Americana Shimanand
Gozi Aishi, autrice nigériane émigré aux
États-Unis qui tu vois, je te parlais
tout à l'heure de la vie d'Antoine et de
ce que c'est
de la vie de Saint-Antoine père des
moines. Ce que c'est que le mal et ben
là Americana, ce que c'est que le
racisme aux États-Unis ? Est-ce que
c'est aussi que être une africaine qui
va aux États-Unis, qui revient dans son
pays au Nigéria, c'est passionnant. Par
ailleurs, ça jette un éclairage sur la
société contemporaine nigériane qui est
probablement l'un des enfin c'est un des
pays les plus fous du monde et dont peu
de gens parlent en France. C'est
remarquable et je pense que c'est un
bouquin qui est d'actualité. Et du coup,
tu disais conseil aux générations
futures, euh bah ne prenez pas votre
carte dans un parti politique. Allez
plutôt faire ce que vous aimez et d'une
manière qui vous paraît juste euh
rentrer dans des fablables, créer des
scopes. La forme dont la façon dont vous
travaillez, la façon dont vous apprenez,
la façon dont vous vous nourrissez, la
façon dont vous interagissez avec les
autres sont des engagements politiques.
Donc engagez-vous autant que vous y
arrivez parce que c'est pas facile mais
engagez-vous parce que on va pas y
arriver tout seul et on est on sera
jamais assez.
Henry, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Je poursuis dans la continuité. Ne cro
ne croyez pas ceux qui vous disent que
c'est pas possible.
Euh quoi que ce soit d'ailleurs, vous ce
que vous pouvez faire, ce que ce que ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble. Ne croyez pas
non plus ceux qui disent "On sait
comment faire, fais-moi nous confiance,
on va le faire. Vote pour nous, on va le
faire nous". Euh soyez soyez attentifs,
méfiez-vous des dogmes, des réponses
toutes faites. Continuez à vous poser
des questions, cherchez pas
nécessairement les réponses.
La la réponse, c'est la faillite de la
question, c'est le malheur de la
question. La question, elle ouvre des
perspectives et tout est possible. Une
réponse est le faire, mais c'est fini
quoi. On sait, on sait que la terre est
plate. On sait que tel ou tel groupe est
méchant et que nous, on est bon. Voilà.
Méfiez-vous des réponses, posez-vous des
questions, ça fait avancer.
On passe le bonjour à votre troisème
compère Julien. Oui, Julien nous manque
qui n'était pas avec nous. On l'embrasse
et on vous remercie messieurs d'être
venu chez nous.
Merci. Merci. Merci à toi. Merci à vous.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]